Yeah, like uh somebody told me I I'll go through that thread
in just a little bit, but somebody told me I guess
that I refuse to cover anything that doesn't go against Destiny
because I won't cover the transcript.
And I said, but you understand that I covered the the preliminary
injunction being denied. Like this hearing happened as a part
of a preliminary injunction motion. I covered the final result
of this like what this hearing led to the result of it.
Did that help? But, you know, yeah, trying to trying to, you
know, speak logic to people who are in a cult is not very effective.
It's okay. You covered many core outcomes that weren't favorable
to Pixie. Yeah, I know. I It's just like I literally covered
this outcome. I covered the outcome of this.
I don't ba basically what they want is they know that Destiny's
lawyer asked a bunch of questions. They want those blasted publicly
and then they know that Pixie says like a lot in the transcript.
So they want us to be mad at Pixie for saying like a lot and
then
oh and then I guess the uh this humiliation it's just like well
pay me money. Pay me money and maybe okay we'll see if you pay.
Okay.
All right.
I saw Dude, I don't even I I know it's like better not to engage
at all, but I do have to pull up one thing. Okay. There's something
Desessie said, "Oh, Pixie is even more disgusting. She's done
something even more disgusting." And like, oh, thank thankfully
we'll be at the end soon. It's like the same vague post he's
done like a million times before, but there's a subreddit thread
about it. I'll just I'll just cover it because I I literally
want to I I just
It's like getting astronomically
It's so much crazier than I thought it would be.
What is it? Here it is. I'll open up uh I'll open up the browser.
Give me a second. Just cover this real quick off the bat.
Just kind of funny.
Okay. Are you guys You guys see me? You see me? Okay. Is this
right here? Oh, we'll just go through it real quick cuz it's
funny. Uh for those who live through the Mr. Girl saga and the
Harvey Weinstein accusations, this is wild.
It's almost like, by the way, it's almost like I've seen it,
so I'm not going to say like I'm prognosticating here cuz I'm
not. But it's crazy that whoever Destiny's who's whoever's currently
annoying Destiny is like the person who most deserves everything
bad in the world, right? Like I kind of leaned out of covering
his stuff uh to cover other interesting
and and I'm I'm no longer talked about and now it's Pixie is
the worst human being on planet Earth. Worse than anyone
Was a roast fake? Um, I can't talk about any of that until that
starts showing up in court filings.
That's going to be um I shouldn't even joke about it. That's
going to be a that's just
it's just the mo just Pixie is the most disgusting person I think
I've ever had the displeasure of engaging with in my entire life.
Her and >> the most disgusting. >> Her and Lauren.
Um >> her and Lauren. >> But that'll I mean we'll
we'll get through that. We'll get there. Why'd you beat Simon
off stream? I This guy's acting like he didn't get he didn't
try to get a random former friend of his who likes Pixie deported
for yelling at him in his hotel or in his uh apartment lobby.
Like this person apparently went and yelled at him in the lobby
of their of their apartment complex. And for that he's decided
I'm going to get them deported. I'm going to try to I'm going
to try to weaponize my audience to get them deported. >> I
had [laughter] nothing else to do. Okay. I've been flying around
so much. >> Uh worse than Mr. Girl. easily, easily, easily,
easily, easily. But you'll see, you'll you'll see. >> Pixie
is like worse than Mr. Girl now. Very cool. Very cool.
Very goofy. All right. Uh there's just one post here that I had
to grab cuz it's so funny. Oh, here we go. So, what what's right
now the most popular skits interpretation of the veg posts? I
This is the most upvoted one, by the way. I've seen people floating
the idea that Rose and Solo were actually some Russian honeypot
scheme. Reminder that Tenant Media, a conservative media group
funded by Russia for propaganda, were getting Dave Rubin to upload
generic Destiny's lol videos. So, it's possible he's in Russian
disinfo apparatus sites.
Perhaps for all the Where is this said in any of the legal filings?
What? Huh?
Uh, perhaps for all of the money DG gives directly to Ukrainian
military
in a world where VP is calling out Twitch streamers. It I believe
it. I believe it. I I believe it, guys. It It just seems likely
at this point that this is all like Russia. Russia did this.
I By the way, the fact the idea of it being a honeypot, not even
really that crazy, like a nationally interested honeypot. I don't
I just need to see some evidence, right? Extraordinary claims
and such.
Gentle whale, thanks for the 11 months. Appreciate it, buddy.
How does the honeypot make Pixie bad? Uh, I don't know. Okay,
so I don't believe that, but some of the comments I see Okay.
Yeah, sure. Sure.
Definitely seems to be botted stuff somewhere some someplace.
Solo equals Rose is top keek if true.
What this is? Oh, this is the one I think they try to run with
is like he was just messaging the guy,
but then he's still retaining and he still ducks the girl who
was I guess then objectively the trafficking victim which is
bizarre to me. I don't know how this makes it better, right?
He would have docked like a trafficking victim if this were the
case.
Also, that trafficking victim would have been wearing DG merch
and sending pictures to just him or just the boyfriend to send
to him. I don't even I man I I don't know. I It's hard to track
this all the way through. It kind of doesn't make any sense.
I just thought it was really funny that the most upvoted one
was was this guy right here. Uh yeah. Anyway, this is a wait
andsee moment. I don't even know what that means. No idea. Okay.
All right. Oh boy. the caffeine will kick in at some point. You
know, he said it's getting filed, so we will see it. Well, no.
I think he
I I don't know if it's getting filed, so we will see it. I I
assume he could talk about his own filings.
And I don't imagine
I don't Did Pixie commit fraud, though? I have no idea. I haven't
looked into any of the Truth of the Pixie stuff. What's getting
filed? Oh, uh, did I not watch the clip? Yeah, we watch We just
watched the clip. Maximus,
did you not you literally just go back like 4 minutes in the
stream?
He he said like I can't talk about it until it comes out in filings.
Pixie's
Yeah, Pixie's disgusting. Okay. All
Stardust going hard on Lily Gatis
earlier today. Is at the Lily Gatis a man? I didn't even I didn't
really get to finish this on stream, but here are the results
of my investigation. Transvestigating Lily Gatis. Let's go. Oh,
I'm I'm spoiling. I'm spoiling. I don't want to spoil.
Is Lily Gatis a man? No. Mancoded
Uh male androgynous.
Okay. So, the the wide nose, the large nose. We're doing physiotomy.
We're doing physioy on Lily Gatis.
Okay. Apparently, this was the route Stardust wanted to go today.
Physiotomy review on
Lily Gatis. I only I know Stardust is a woman because she's about
as funny as a rock.
Yeah. Yeah, that be that be true. That be true.
The uh
Hold on. Lily Gatis, unfortunately for Stardust, responded. Okay,
she's about 493 likes. Know your place. You look like a rat.
And then she posted a picture of Stardust.
Now, realistically, that's a pretty
flattering picture of Stardust. It's not like a bad picture,
but yeah, you look like a rat. Now, here's the thing.
I thought Lily Gatis' whole vibe was being racist. How did she
use a slur, like a slur used, a canard used against people against
an Indian woman? Are you actually so bad? You're so incompetent.
You're so terrible at racism that you tried to do
you you failed racism against an Indian on Twitter. That is like
the that is
that's like learning to crawl as an infant. Okay. That's like
the first thing you learn on Twitter. That's Twitter's version
of learning to crawl is how to be racist towards Indians. I Yeah,
it it was like the wor it's the worst attempt at racism I've
ever seen. It could have been so easy. Yeah, it could have been
so easy. She really is
Oh, that's a good angle. Yeah, she really is grifting.
Where is it? Here. Yeah, I Dude, I had to call this out. What
the can't even be racist to Indian people. Tell us what she should
have said. Um,
some combination of the Sargon AOD comment towards his political
opponent in that race and combine that with the story about goats
in India getting gang wrecked to death. Okay, you put those two
things together, you get a tweet. But I'm not I'm never going
to combine those things into a tweet. That would be really really,
you know, racist and and demeaning. I'll never combine those
things into the whole package. But you put those things together,
you got a tweet. Okay.
Yeah. I'm not I just I don't I don't engage in that level of
racism. Okay. Clip from that Stardust stream. Her making the
meme.
Okay.
Uh try the Stardust challenge. How long can you stand watching
this mindless bent tweet at tweets from Star before the psychic
damage overwhelms you? Can you make it to her talking about how
stupid she seems? Her mentioning her weird face. What else is
hiding inside?
Hold on. Okay, we've got a timer right here. I'm not going to
add the music back yet. Let's just see how long we can go. All
right. Um, when you got to tap out, start start putting cash
stare in the chat. All right. When you have to tap out.
>> Goddess, does she have breasts? I don't see any breasts
in this.
>> Um I feel like I'm
I feel like I'm much more intelligent than I like let on. Right.
Um I definitely like I think I present myself in a much less
intelligent way than than I actually think. >> Wait, no.
We should do something other than cash stare. I didn't mean to
use the one Indian emote I had. >> But when I get like
duded, like yeah, it it's like all out the window. Like there's
no thoughts in brain, you know. >> I This is horrible optics
for anybody clipping this right now. God damn it.
I just meant the thousand yard stare. [__] me.
>> No mammary glands. No female organs. All right. No breasts
ever in any picture.
>> Why do I look so stupid, man? I look so stupid. It's
so awkward. You'll see like in all my all my pictures I always
do like the closed mouth smile because I always like I always
feel like
it's really awkward. The open mouth smile is really awkward.
I look like I'm
>> God, I have this to continue. >> You know, I just
look really really uncomfortable or I look awkward. I feel like
I look awkward. Dude,
there's no fear either. >> I think I might actually be
on to
What the Yeah. So, I'm just getting used to my face, my face
angle and my face like
from the IRL perspective, right? I don't know if I'll ever get
used to it to be honest. I think you just have to like be okay
with like looking awkward,
>> That's a real thing. Okay. Oh my god. Thank god I can
like kind of empathize slightly. There's like there's like the
the picture you could have or the the image that you would show
up with on a computer when you're like webcamming with people
when you have like the right angle, little bit of lighting, and
then there's there's somehow when you're in IRL settings and
you see yourself on a video camera, you're not used to that.
Oh, that is way different. All right. It's way different.
All right. It's way different. Yeah. I obviously do it for work.
I've been I've been on a lot of uh voice calls or video calls.
Brother, brother man.
>> What I was not expecting was the male attention. Okay.
I was not expecting the male attention. >> Oh boy. >> From
the alien suit. As soon as I put the alien suit on, like there
was one dude who was started hitting on me and his like his girl
came over and she was >> There's no way that she's ex She's
There's no way. There's just no way on planet Earth that she's
going to sit here and go,
"Guys, as soon as I covered up 99%
of my physical appearance,
all the guys started hitting. There's Please. I don't have the
strength to just leave this alone. It's so up. I'm just trying
to not be an for two seconds
off." And and then God tried to like lower the tension and he
kept hitting on me and he kept and then he started like he started
like offering me his >> Why? This is so unrequired.
Why did this have to come? That's so weird. What the
>> [__] what is Zen? I don't know what Zins
are. It just comes in a can. He was offering it to me and I wasn't
understanding what he was saying to me because, you know, I'm
like hearing all this crinkling around me and and then he's like
being real quiet to me. Um, but I think he was trying to offer
me this. What? It must be like tobacco or something. I don't
know. Well, anyways, he was trying to offer it to me and he was
like doing this motion with it like just take it, you know. And
then um and I was so confused at what he was trying to tell me
to do and then his his girl came over and she was like, I don't
think the alien wants to put it up their leg. And I was like,
oh, he's trying to get me to put it up my leg so I can have it
inside the suit. And then she took him away and she was so mad
at him and I was like [laughter]
what's the [__] is going then there was another guy
who was like taking a picture with me and then he was like can
I kiss you and I was like and and I was like no not >> I'll
be honest I'm really just torturing you guys I'm doing in the
background I'm like sending messages looking at other [__]
[laughter] >> kiss but then I thought maybe he's >> I'm
like not looking at the stream monitor at all >> being
like you know this clearly this man isn't going to actually kiss
me on the mouth right [laughter] I thought he was Oh, like pretend
kiss with the alien, you know, cuz he's taking a picture with
the >> uh Okay. All right. I mean, we only have like 30
seconds left. We can finish. >> He meant like actual kiss
kiss, right? And like he was trying to kiss me on the mouth.
Luckily, I turned away in time, but holy like this dude that
like I don't know. I've never been so harassed in my life. this
in, >> bro. I
>> insane. It is actually insane.
I don't know what the Yeah. through the suit. He literally tried
to kiss me on the mouth. I turned away.
>> There's I
Why Why am I supposed to Oh, why am I supposed to >> Just
in time. But uh and he like landed on my head. But like this
dude was actually trying to
>> just saying again
that
she's basically saying I've never been hit on. I've never been
so much in my life as when I put on a suit that showed nothing
about my face body to anybody around me. And that's a claim she
wants to make in public on stream
>> trying to kiss me on the mouth. I don't know what it
is about the alien costume, guys. Like the alien costume literally
got me harassed all night. Which >> do I want to start
off? I think we're going to do I realize that you guys might
not be quite so into it, but >> inside the Democratic party,
>> we are we are going to watch the full Ezra Klein oped.
Okay, 28 minutes. This is how Democrats win.
All right, lots of people not big fans of Mr. Ezra Klein nowadays.
Okay, sort of become the the epitome of liberalism in a lot of
people's minds. the thing that we have to defeat. I do want to
see what he says. Um, for the exact same reason that if you if
you think this guy's your enemy, you should know what he thinks,
right? It's like very important to know what your enemy thinks.
Why is he wearing a tie? I'm not sure. Thank you. All right.
I don't know why he's wearing a tie. He's just looking professional.
What do you mean why is he wearing a tie? He's trying to look
professional. Do his whole thing. All right. So, we're going
to check this out.
I'm quite interested. We've got this. We've got some tactical
templar later. Oh, also
we might do I don't we might have to leave this for kick. I don't
know where it's going to go. Okay, but I've been linked some
Proopa Insights physiotomy analysis videos that I do want to
check out as well. All right, we might have to leave that for
kick cuz I'm not sure where those videos are going to go. Uh
they may go to not great places.
We'll see. We'll see. We'll see.
Anyway, let's uh let's check this out. We've got Tactical Templar
coming up in just a bit and then after the Proopa videos, Tactical
Templar quick mom Donnie update and then maybe the Piers Morgan
stuff. Then we're going to get to Spooky Sunday. All right. Or
whenever we run out of time. Either one.
Use Kick that tracks. Oh, well thank you.
Yeah, I don't know if you are, but obviously the entire chat's
on kick basically. So >> it's back room.
It's group chats and its conferences and it's online flame wars.
An increasingly bitter debate has taken hold over what the party
needs to do to become capable of beating back Trumpism. Do Democrats
need to become more populist,
more moderate,
more socialist?
Do they need to embrace the abundance agenda? Do they need to
produce more vertical video? The answer is >> that's weird
to me. Um,
why do you just reference abundance like you didn't write the
book? Yes, they do. All of them. But none of them in particular.
The Democratic Party does not need to choose to be one thing.
It needs to choose to be more things.
In a few days, there will be elections for mayor of New York
City, for governor of New Jersey, and for governor of Virginia.
As of now, Democrats are >> Oh my god. My my Big 10 party
has to make an even bigger tent, guys. A way bigger tent. Listen,
the the issue we we need abundance in terms of raw cloth, okay?
Raw polyester for tent size. We need bigger tents. Everyone needs
bigger tents right now immediately. Bigger tents. It's all about
bigger tents. We're leading in all these races. These aren't
unusual leads in what have become reliably Democratic states.
>> You can imagine a world
>> where the violence and corruption
of Donald Trump's first nine months in office you gambling with
World War II >> had led to a collapse in support for him
and his party. We'll see what election day actually brings. But
we do not look to be in that world. That's all the more true
if you look a year out to the midterms.
Democrats are leading by about 2 and a half points. At about
this time in 2017,
Democrats were up by about 10 points. Democrats have another
problem. They're going to need to overcome the chain of redistricting
Republicans are setting off across the country. There may be
more of a pad here. Did we watch this on stream or did I just
No, I don't think we did. I watched the Lib and Learn episode
where they talked about redistricting quite a bit. Uh I watched
that off stream. Uh it's it's interesting. I don't think it's
like
insane or totally disastrous. It's like Republicans will get
more of an advantage. Democrats are going to have to wait to
get their gerrymandering in. um
more just like it it it's going to be bad like as it is now,
but I think you just look to gain more of an advantage voting
wise
like like they might I think the I don't know some people are
hoping they'll jerrymander to the point that they become like
really brittle but for
>> and the Senate the Senate is even harder for Democrats.
They will need to flip four seats in the 2026 midterms to win
back the Senate. That mean winning in Maine and North Carolina?
No easy task. And then winning at least two seats in states that
Donald Trump won by 10 points or more. The map for Democrats
wasn't always this daunting. Go back to 2010 and 10 of those
states had Democratic senators.
Today, none of them do. Most of those states seem barely in reach
for Democrats.
There's no arguing with this fact.
The number of places in which Democratic Party is competitive
has shrunk. In American politics, power is not decided by a popular
vote. In the electoral college, in the House of Representatives,
and particularly in the >> I love that there's probably
an argument that
the Democratic Party is most hurt by its h there's some argument
that like the inauthenticity, the willingness to lie to voters,
like they had strangle holds in a bunch of places like Ohio.
Okay, maybe not. No, I think Ohio I think Ohio they like maybe
not strangle holds. Ohio's always a flip state. Sorry, a swing
state. But like in the Midwest, okay, in the rust belt, they
had a strangle hold and they've like lost that because those
people don't trust them anymore.
I think that's like the big thing. How do you start propagandizing
so people don't trust Republicans too would be sort of where
I think you have to go. It is a portion by place. This is the
problem for Democrats. They don't just need to win more people,
they need to win more places.
And that requires a different kind of thinking. If Zoran Mani
wins the New York City mayor's race and Rob Sand wins the Iowa
governor's race next year, >> the Democratic and Republican
parties don't solve enough problems to deserve their little shared
monopoly. >> Did the Democratic party just move left or
right? Neither. It got bigger. It found a way to represent more
kinds of people in more kinds of places. That is a spirit it
needs to embrace. Not
not progressivism,
but in the classic political sense of the term
In 196
um okay,
I'm going to have to watch because to me what Ezra Klein's saying
here is
all the people looking to cut Hassan out. Those people that's
what Ezra Ezra Klein's saying it now. If the if the god of the
abundance mindset is saying it, how will some of these online
liberal influencers resist? >> 62. Bernard Crick published
this strange little book called In Defense of Politics.
Politics for Crick is something precious and specific.
It quote arises from accepting the fact of the simultaneous existence
of different groups, hence different interests and different
traditions within a territorial unit under common rule.
I know that's a a mouthful, but that fact of difference he is
pointing out, the reality of difference is not always accepted.
There are other forms of social order like tyranny or oligarchy
that actively suppress it. But to practice politics as Craig
defines it, is to accept the reality of difference. That is to
say, it is to accept the reality of other people, of how different
other people are from you. Politics involves genuine relationships
with people who are genuinely other people, not tasks set for
our redemption or objects for our philanthropy.
So far, I'm I'm not hating the video. Um, I think people are
going to hate the video because of who's making it, who the opinion
is from. It's not like I think this opinion is bad yet. Okay,
it's not like I think it's bad yet.
He's got to have some way. This is, in my opinion, another attempt
at paradigm shift. It's just a different version, right? But
it is like an an attempt at a paradigm shift. I'll listen. I'll
listen with an open ear. Okay. genuine
people who are genuinely other people.
>> I love that line because the endless fantasy in politics
is persuasion without representation.
You elect us to represent you and where we disagree, we will
explain to you why you are wrong.
The result of that politics tends to be neither persuasion nor
representation.
People know when you're not listening to them and they know how
to respond.
They stop listening to you. They vote for people who they feel
do listen to them. I'm not a pessimist on the possibility of
persuasion, but I believe it is rare, maybe impossible,
outside a context of mutual respect. And if I were to say where
the Democratic party went most wrong over the last decade, it's
there. In too many places, Democrats sought persuasion without
representation.
And so they got neither. I've spent much of the last year talking
to the kinds of voters Democrats lament losing. I feel I end
up having the same conversation over and over again.
>> Oh, this is not good. Okay. This is not good. How Okay.
You have a like national you have like a federal system or you
you have a system where there's a bunch of like
Yeah. federally elected officials. How are they going to represent
everybody if you're going to represent a whole bunch of different
I don't I don't understand how this works. You're saying you
want to go wider, bigger tent. That'll be more opinions where
people offset. I don't I don't know. He's got to find a way to
tie this together. And it makes no sense to me currently. >> They
sometimes tell me about issues where the Democratic Party departed
from them. But they first describe a more fundamental feeling
of alienation. The Democratic Party, they came to believe, doesn't
like them. Many of these people voted for Democrats until a few
years ago. They didn't feel their fundamental beliefs had changed,
but they began to feel like deplorables.
They began to feel unwanted.
>> 250
million people are not garbage. I could tell you who the real
garbage is, but we won't say that. When I'd push on the experiences
they had, when I would ask which Democrats were they talking
about, what exactly had happened, [gasps] I often found they
were reacting to a a cultural vibe as much or more than a flesh
and blood party. They had felt something change.
And I knew they were right because something had changed. It
had changed on the left. It had changed on the right. But it
was diffuse. It wasn't any one person or any one moment or any
one policy. The structure of American life changed in a way that
has made the genuine relationships of politics much harder to
maintain. I believe the first party that figures out its way
out of this trap will be the one able to build a majority in
this era. When I grew up, >> okay, so he's clearly identifying
the need for a major paradigm shift. He's talking about it. I
just he's he's like laid out some ideas that seem contradictory
to me. So, I'm I'm hoping he can he can somehow twist this in
a way that makes the cont what what I perceive as contradictions
make sense. >> In a Republican county an hour south of
Los Angeles, my family subscribed to the Los Angeles Times and
to the extent I heard political commentary, it was on local radio.
>> 2005 was a tough year for public California state and
local taxes are >> Good afternoon, Senator McClintto. Good
afternoon, Senator Seinberg.
Now, the New York Times is the largest newspaper by subscribers
in California. And a young politicallyincclined kid like I was
will listen to podcasts like Welcome to Pod Save America. I'm
John >> I'm John Love. >> I'm Tommy Vtor. >> On
today's show, we'll talk about Donald Trump's latest musings
about doing away with the Constitution to become president for
life. >> Trump. President Trump. >> Um Trump. Talk
me through your evolution on Trump. Sure. that kid's political
sensibility will be less distinctly Californian and more relentlessly
national. For decades, we have been losing local media and migrating
to national media. And that has meant politics everywhere is
losing its local character and reflecting national
>> So, how do you how do you do like a national party while
also maintaining local character? I mean, this literally it's
not hard to describe the problem. Then there is the astonishing
amount of money politicians need and the places they go to find
it.
In the 1970s, the Supreme Court decided money was speech. >> The
expenditure limitations
are violative of first amendment guarantees
and they are
>> Campaigns became more expensive
and candidates often need a whole lot more money than what they
can raise in their own states and districts. That means exciting
donors who are much further to the left or right than the public
and winning over interest groups that seek their support on policy.
Money can
Money can corrupt. But either way, it pulls candidates away from
their own constituents. That was all true when I moved to Washington
to cover politics in 2005.
But then something else changed.
But what we're going to do is get rid of all these buttons
and just make a giant screen. 800 million Facebook users are
coming to grips with change this week. >> It features scrolling
news feeds and snazzier pictures >> by showing you older
tweets it thinks you care about right on top of your current
feed. >> We're not going to touch the phones.
>> Can't touch it no matter what happens. >> It's
a serious problem. >> It really is. >> How much time
do you spend doing this? The average smartphone user scrolls
the equivalent of 78 miles a year. That's >> I've I've
somehow managed to avoid this and it's like why I suck at Twitter.
I I literally like can't do it. I can't make it happen, man.
I don't know. This is I I reject this in my in my soul somehow.
And I feel I feel like it stops me from using Twitter effectively.
Okay. Phones suck and are for normies. I just mean like I can't
scroll Twitter endlessly or like and I I literally stay away
from shorts feeds because I I think that's terrifying.
But this is old Darius. Wait, it is. What the Who is this guy?
Wait, hold on.
This is
I see it. I can't not see it now that you pointed it out. What
the hell?
>> Green marathons. >> Hold on.
>> Daddy catching multiple cases. Daddy's sperm sent letters
on gold foil pages. You look half dead in the booking station.
I said you look like heaven. We stop for gas off the I55.
You dream about robbing the pump guy blind. I laugh too hard
and you didn't reply. >> Just let your vape and stick her
>> and you talk about her like a knife in the heart. Hannah
on your MIND LIKE FORGET ME NOT. I PLAY THE NAVIGATOR. I SONG
YOU STUPID VERSE. I HAVE A [screaming] LOT. Everyone says you're
USING ME,
but not in the way I dreamed you would be. It's selfish and it's
>> okay. This is the This is the Kerbine song. I I listen,
it's a great song. I'm probably not going to continue with it
right now. We all know this politics, but for all the words that
have been spilled on it, I think we still miss how fundamentally
it has altered the day-to-day work of politics since the 2024.
I don't think I mean, it's changed everything. Like, literally,
nobody's caught up. Everybody with power in Washington is still
not caught up. I I feel like who's who's underestimating this?
I feel like a lot of people know >> election. There's been
a lot of talk on the Democratic side about the power of the so-called
groups. >> There are interest groups. There were a lot
of advocacy groups, a lot of parts of the Democratic party that
really thought things were fine. >> They're more extreme
than many of their >> The progressive advocacy organizations
and nonprofits that have arguably pushed Democrats to the left.
I've used that term before. I've talked about the groups, but
I think it is imprecise. The real thing we're talking about here
is what might be called the professional political classes. The
people in the groups are the same people who staff or drive all
the other parts of progressive politics. One year you're with
a nonprofit, then you're on a campaign, then you're in the White
House, then you're back at a group. You're followed on X or Blue
Sky by left-leaning journalists like me, by producers at MSNBC,
or by breaking news reporters at Politico.
It's not a bunch of groups. It's a professional community that
exists largely online. And so that professional community's culture
and its attention
is governed not by its own values or goals, but by the decisions
of the corporations and oligarchs who own the social media platforms
who design them to further their own profits or their own politics.
The conversations pulsing across these platforms are shaped not
by civic values, but by the hacks that keep people scrolling.
Nuanced opinions get compressed into viral slogans.
Attention collects around the loudest and most controversial
voices. And the algorithms they love conflict and inspiration
and outrage and anger. Everything is always turned up to 11.
Social media has thrown everyone involved at every level of politics
in every place into the same algorithmic thunderdome.
It collapsed distance and profession and time because no matter
where we are or when we are, we can always be online together.
We always know what our most online peers are thinking. They
come to set the culture of their respective political classes.
And there is nothing that most of us fear like being out of step
with our
This has affected the Democratic and Republican parties in different
ways. Let me start with the Democrats. From 2012 to 2024,
Democrats moved sharply left on virtually every issue. They often
did so believing they were finally representing communities that
had long suffered from too little representation.
This was what they were told by the online voices and by the
professional groups that claimed to represent those communities.
But it went wrong. Democrats became more uncompromising on immigration
and lost support among Hispanic voters. They moved left on guns
and student loans and climate and lost ground with young voters.
They moved left on race and lost ground with black voters. They
move left on education and lost ground with Asian-Americans.
>> Okay. So, in my opinion,
in my opinion, they um
this is when you have a big tent. Of course, you're going to
make decisions that represent the group overall and offend one
of your interest groups specifically. And it's just like,
oh, there's like a there's got to be a name for like this phenomenon.
It's like imagining, okay, you work at a job.
It's the idea that like you can never accept less from a specific
thing, right? basically like Asian voters, black voters, they
used to feel like they got a better deal from the Democrat party
and as the deal changed for them, it wasn't quite as good for
them, right? They they kept accept they they don't want to accept
less and so they either abstain or they go vote for the other
party, right?
That's that's the issue is like there's this idea that the Democrats
are representing them less. But this is an idea of having a big
tent party
and and you can't represent all of the groups in that big tent
party. So now he's saying, "I want to go bigger tent."
And I'm not sure how this same thing doesn't happen, right? I
I don't know. It's I don't understand
because realistically the the Republicans have gone more in a
direction where their populist voices, their online voices direct
them and they become more popular, right?
So how do you explain that the Republicans have become more extreme
in a ton of their views and they've not lost support in the same
way? Like I I'm going to ask basically if if both parties are
doing this, why are you acting like the Democrats are the only
or sorry, why is it factual that the Democrats are the only people
who are losing support
voters that we've left on economics and lost ground with workingclass
voters? The only major group where Democrats saw improvement
across that whole 12-year period was college educated white voters.
If you judged democratic politics expressively by what it was
saying, it stood in solidarity with the struggling and the marginalized
as never before. If you judged it consequentially, it was breaking
faith with those it had vowed to represent and protect.
Online politics is expressive. You need to say what will win
favor with the highly online voices that dominate your side of
the algorithm. Offline,
you need to win elections. I sued EPA and I'll take dead aim
at the captain. >> Oh no, Joe Mansion. Everybody hates
this >> trade bill because it's bad for West
>> Yes, that was Mansion shooting the capp trade bill the
Democrats have been trying to pass with a rifle.
But Mansion 12 years later was the key vote to pass the Inflation
Reduction Act, the single largest green energy investment in
American history. this is a great day because this is a balanced
bill.
>> Expressively to progressives, Mansion was just a constant
irritant.
Consequentially, he was the Democrat's most remarkable overperformer.
He made their majority possible by winning elections. No Democrat
should have been able to win. >> In a state that the president
in the previous election won by 42 points, the opposite [cheering]
party wins. Never happened. Never happened.
The most important question the party needed to be asking in
that era was where do they find more Joe Mansions? How do they
make more Joe Mansions
But today's Democratic party, particularly its online culture,
has taken forms of disagreement and difference it once held inside
its tent and pushed them outside. >> West Virginia's most
prominent Democrat changed his registration to independent today.
There are very fewer and fewer people like you in the Senate.
I mean, is that >> Well, my calling to say thank God.
>> Yes, they would. Including some in your former party.
>> Oh, many in my former party. [laughter] >> In
2010, when the Affordable Care Act passed, the crucial vote in
the Senate came from Ben Nelson, a pro-life
>> After winning fresh concessions to limit the availability
of abortions. >> But I would have not voted for this bill
and would not vote for this bill without those provisions. There
were then roughly 40 pro-life Democrats serving in the House
crafting compromises across. >> I like this because this
is literally the Hutch versus Strader conversation, right? This
is like a big part of it. And now Ezra Klein's given me a video
where I can hear his opinions sort of as concisely and as succinctly
as possible. >> These disagreements was hard, but Democrats
are able to pass Obamacare, which expanded reproductive health
coverage and remains the greatest Democratic policy accomplishment
of the 21st century. We are done.
>> That same Democratic party with all of its internal
disagreements, it had the votes to confirm Supreme Court justices
who would and did in their time protect row. I've been in a debate
recently about whether Democrats should run pro-life candidates
in red states in much the way that Republicans run pro-choice
candidates like Susan Collins and Larry Hogan in blue states.
And I think I was taken aback to hear people say in response
to this argument that I just wanted to throw reproductive rights
overboard.
So I want to say this
No, I don't. I thought past episodes I've done on abortion, episodes
I've done in the context of what my own family has been through
should have shown that. But what I want >> Well, they they
don't. You just have to explain it. >> What? Hold on. I
think if you're going to start going this new direction, you
should be willing to explain it at that time. So, I thought I
thought like all of my past work would have shown this. People
might not be familiar with your past work and it's a pretty controversial
thing to to say. Is the Democratic Party big enough and strong
enough to protect reproductive rights and I feel our politics
on this have failed
because they have failed. We cannot protect or restore
reproductive freedom if the coalition that cares about that cannot
compete in more places. But this point is not about any one issue.
It's about a broader approach to politics.
Different places have different politics and to win in them.
Politicians have to represent the people who live. >> Here's
the weird thing, right?
I think you should run people who are from that state who represent
like that state's values or whatever in in different elections,
right? And maybe that means running somebody who's
but and they could seem more authentic. It's like I don't want
that person to be like lying.
I don't know. Oh man, it's
I can see what he's saying that there's like not really downside
and it's possible, you know, if you get if you pick up like two
senators somehow from this, right? That you can pass a whole
bunch of other Democratic policy where you where there's overlap
and yes, you will not have the same strength when it comes to
abortion stuff, but realistically, if those people were red,
you wouldn't have the strength there
But then it becomes like, okay, on a federal level, on a national
level, you are basically saying, even though our party doesn't
stand for this, we're going to run people who are they'll say
they're pro-life, but everybody will know that they're not going
to be able to get anything accomplished at a federal level on
pro-life
or national level and pro-life for pro the pro-life cause. I'm
trying to think of like how this goes overall in my head. I'm
not I'm not sure. I guess what I what I wanted from Ezra and
what straight asked for was examples of where this might have
made a difference and then examples of like I I just want a a
solid example that could let me visualize why this is better.
So I understand that hey Democrats used to have people who were
represented a more broad coalition on some specific issues.
That's fine, but that's very different from saying like I I actually
think the Republican party would be the exact same, right? the
Republican party probably used to have candidates who represented
a wider breath of issues. I don't I don't see the evidence that
like the Republican party is broadening and the Democratic party
is narrowing
in in the like he's given me one example which is hey on cultural
issues the Democratic party's moved left and it's it's lost them
voters in certain blocks. Okay, I can understand that. Why is
the Republican party moving rightward? Why is it, okay, in terms
of like we're we're thinking about how can we paradigm shift
here. How can we change the fact that Democrats get judged for
the things they say and Republicans don't? Republicans aren't
held to their word. That's where you have to shift things because
the issue is unless you shift that, it doesn't matter. It doesn't
matter how
it doesn't matter if you allow other views in your party, it
it really doesn't. It's
it's going to be how the voters react to it. It's like it's like
the voters will still react badly if you if you don't get stuff
done for them.
And for some reason, the Republicans, even though a bunch of
Republican states are voting to overturn abortion laws, right?
They're voting to overturn a lot of the stringent laws they would
have had, even some of the like, oh, what is it? The instantly
triggering laws. I know some states had as soon as Row was gone,
they had laws that immediately took precedent on the books, right?
I'm sitting here and I'm thinking like, how does that not hurt
Republicans nationally? That's my big question is is the fact
that the the constituents seem to not actually vibe with being
pro-life in like as stringent a way as they advertise as the
federal or sorry, the national party for the Republicans advertises.
How do they make that work? What is the what is the secret sauce
there? You either copy that or you give me some other paradigm
shift. And I don't know that just like oh we should just be more
accepting in of like different candidates. I don't know if that's
really what it is.
There's like something else going on there. I I don't know if
it's just being accepting or not like attacking other candidates
for their beliefs >> live in them. That means representing
views Democrats now. >> If that were the case, how are
the Gropers carving out any section? The Gropers are the most
intolerant section of the Republican party. How are they carving
out any piece of the pie in terms of the national conversation
for American politics? They don't have a ton of power. They don't
have a ton of connections. They don't have a ton of political
capital. How are they carving out this thing as the most intolerant
group on the right? Yeah. I don't know. There's like a lot of
questions. >> I find to be anathema on immigration or guns
or trade or climate or trans rights. But one worry I have about
Democrats right now is that they do not want to confront how
much of the country truly deeply disagrees with them. Polls show
that the percentage of voters saying the Democratic Party is
too liberal increased sharply between 2012 and 2024.
The percentage of voters saying the Republican party is too conservative
fell during that same
Even now >> yes. So, we all will agree. You can use this.
I totally I have no problem with saying this, but we're gonna
totally disagree. I think I will totally disagree with his recline
on what caused this shift specifically. >> After the aggression
and the outrages and the violations
of Trump's second administration, that gap has not fully
I would like to believe that all Democrats need to do to win
back these voters is embrace an agenda I'm already comfortable
with. economic populism or abundance or both. But I don't think
it's true. A study by the Center for Working Class Politics found
that in key Rusfeld states, when you attached the Democratic
label to a candidate running on an economic populist platform,
that candidate lost 11 to 16 points in support.
That's how Sherid Brown, once one of the strongest economic populists
in the party, lost his Ohio. I think uh dude I I'm
man people are saying a lot of different reasons. I think it's
it's not just economy. I think it's just co and trans rights.
I think those are the two places where people feel like Democrats
overstepped. I think it's just co and trans rights. I think those
two things actually fundamentally shifted stuff in in America.
And I don't know how you get away from that. I don't know how
you
I Yeah. I don't know. I think it's like those two things. I don't
know if you if it's just time to get away from that. Immigration
before trans rights. Immigration's a thing.
I think Oh man, immigration is a huge thing. I agree with you
guys. Immigration is a huge thing. I'm not taking into account.
I'll have to think about it in my in my mind exactly why this
is the case. It could be. Yeah. No, immigration is a big thing
that people want it fixed, right? And people I I don't think
you can convince people that immigration is like more positive
for the economy. It's possible, Kilo. I think I think immigration
is really tangible. I think people can't not see immigration
as a problem. I think it's like I don't know if you'll ever win
that argument. I don't know if you can ever do the overall
I don't know if you'll ever be able to actually successfully
message out like that immigration is not a problem. You can't
do the the immigration isn't a problem. Um I actually it's always
economically positive. I don't think you can ever win that argument
and people are going to keep trying to win that argument and
I think it's is with Democrats majorly. >> Senate seat
to a Republican car dealer who had to settle more than a dozen
lawsuits for wage theft. >> Hold on. I'm uh I'm pulling
this back just a second here. >> That's how Sherid Brown,
once one of the strongest economic populace in the party, lost
his Ohio Senate seat to a Republican car dealer who had to settle
more than a dozen lawsuits for wage
Jared Golden is a Democrat. >> Shared Brown. Who who would
have who would have campaigned in canvas for that guy that he
lost a seat that he used to hold so commandingly >> for
me. Boy, >> in 2024, he edged out a victory in a district
Donald Trump won by nearly 10 >> Working with Republicans
to secure the border and standing with law enforcement against
defunding the >> um while this is true, Porter Beller,
I think people still see immigration as a problem. I don't I
think that's the issue. There's there's like I guess you could
say the economy underlies that, right? People feel like their
living status is going down. They think um quality of life is
going up in other places and they wonder why is America allowing
quality of life to rise all across the globe everywhere in the
third world and American quality of life's going down. That's
what they're >> I'm Jared Golden and I approve this >> Or
American quality of life is stagnating to them. is you deserved
a congressman as independent as you. >> No other Democrat
in Congress, not one, has survived in such a proTrump
>> He is declaring victory, admitting it was his toughest
election yet. >> Now, in what strikes me as an absolutely
insane turn of events, Golden is facing a primary challenge.
>> Golden even said he was okay with Donald Trump becoming
president again. Instead of learning from Democrats like Golden,
Democrats who are successfully representing voters
who are otherwise moving towards Donald Trump, some progressives
want to purge him >> because we can do better than bad
and >> I don't think the Democratic Party should just move
right. It is good in my view that AOC and Zoran Mandani run as
Democrats and that Bernie Sanders has become a leader in the
Democratic party. It is good that you can be an outandout democratic
socialist in today's Democratic party. What happened over the
past 15 years >> is he not understanding that the fact
that like Bernie and Zoron exist is being used to like is is
being weaponized against Democrats in other districts. Like the
exact way
that somebody's going to go, oh, like somebody who's a Dem primary
challenger to Golden is going to say, oh, he said he was okay
with Trump becoming president. Yeah. that your opponent is going
to go, "Oh, this guy's in a party with like AOC and Zora Mani."
Actually, he said he didn't hate Zoro Mamani. Isn't that's concerning?
He doesn't hate communism,
right? So, you're you're saying it's good that you're broadening
and I could maybe believe that somehow, but the national level,
the nationalization of politics is requiring like something else.
He's just like, "Oh, we kind of like lean into it and it's fine."
I don't see a broad base of belief in the Republican party. I
see their their leader chopping heads off until the right opinions
are in place. It's like the exact ah I I've not seen any good
argument for this yet. He's basically looking at some stats and
I think he's ignoring some broader
some some broader things happening. But I I'll keep listening.
is a Democratic party made room on its left and closed down on
its right for all the talk of a Democrat should learn from Sanders
or Mandani and it should learn things from Sanders and Mdani.
There should be at least as much talk of what they should learn
from Joe Mansion or Jared Golden or Marie Glusen Comp Perez.
>> People are valid in their anger
and it's it is a fool's errand to try to talk somebody out of
their feelings. So what you need to do here if you want these
kinds of people to be safe in your party, you have to have like
this core set of policies. You have to have something that's
going to excite people that you can unite around. That's what
you need, right? Maybe it's an economic populism agenda. Maybe
it's like curbing immigration. Maybe it's like some it could
be anything. But you have to have something that they all agree
on, something that unites them, right?
For the Republican party, they did a cult of personality and
it's all Trump sucking. That's like their core value in the world
is is do you wash Trump's balls effectively?
That's what they found is is good, right? And they've kind of
built like a cult around it. I think that's horrible. I think
that needs to be done away with. But in terms of how they're
getting past the fact that they have conflicting opinions in
their party such for as far as they go for as far as much as
they exist, I think it's mostly in this cult of personality.
That's what's causing it. And I don't think Ezra is doing a good
job of explaining how those contradictions won't be weaponized.
He's not explaining like how do you fix the broader cultural
issue at all. He's just sort of like pretending it doesn't exist.
I don't know. Or he even identified it, but he's I don't think
he's solving it effectively.
>> That is not
That's not a good idea.
But you also can affirm the validity of their feelings and also
I have to use the bathroom real quick. Had a ton of caffeine
to start the stream. I'm going I'm rolling it back like a minute
and a half. I'll be right >> As independent as you >> your
hero. I I think Republicans are overstepping as well. I think
it will start to show I think there are core issues that the
Democrats are not being effective on like immigration, like uh
oh, what was the first one I used? It wasn't just immigration.
It was um
Oh, it was trans rights was one of them. What was the other one
I used right off the bat?
Oh, I cannot co. Thank you. Co you can't come back from immigration
is one that you could change. You could take like way harsher
stances on immigration. I don't know why nobody messages it correctly.
It's like, hey, we shouldn't be
I'll talk about it after. I'm just going to hit play. I'll be
right back. No other Democrat in Congress, not one, has survived
in such a proTrump
>> He is declaring victory, admitting it was his toughest
election yet. >> Now, in what strikes me as an absolutely
insane turn of events, Golden is facing a primary challenge.
>> Golden even said he was okay with Donald Trump becoming
president again. Instead of learning from Democrats like Golden,
Democrats who are successfully representing voters
who are otherwise moving towards Donald Trump, some progressives
want to purge him >> because we can do better than bad
and >> I don't think the Democratic party should just move
right. It is good in my view that AOC and Zoran Mandani run as
Democrats and that Bernie Sanders has become a leader in the
Democratic party. It is good that you can be an outandout democratic
socialist in today's Democratic party. But what happened over
the past 15 years is the Democratic party made room on its left
and closed down on its right for all the talk of a Democrat should
learn from Sanders or Mandani and it should learn things from
Sanders and Mdani. There should be at least as much talk of what
they should learn from Joe Mansion or Jared Golden or Marie Glusen
Perez. People are valid in their anger
and it is a fool's errand to try to talk somebody out of their
feelings.
>> That is not that's not a good idea.
But you also can affirm the validity of their feelings and also
present
a productive strategy for
some of those
the drivers of of of that anger [clears throat] or that fear
>> or Sarah McBride. >> You can't foster social change
if you don't have a conversation. You can't change people if
you exclude them. And I will just say, >> oh, Kitty Cinderella,
Kitty Cinderella, >> have absolutism
on the left or the right
without authoritarianism,
right? The fact that we have real disagreements, the fact that
we have difficult conversations, the facts fact that we have
painful conversations is not a a a bug of democracy. It's a feature
of democracy.
And yes, that is hard and and difficult. But again, how can we
expect that the process of overcoming marginalization is going
to be fair? >> The Democratic Party should be >> or
like the Briana Woo build is going to >> that's very rude.
>> The Democratic Party should be >> Oh, there's
a BA tweet we should check out at some point here. >> Internal
disagreement.
It should treat that disagreement as more welcome. >> It
should be looking for a gut level. >> Yeah, I I get it.
I get it. Shut it down. I get why they said what they did. >> With
more of this country.
>> Moderating on this or that issue is more straightforward
than finding ways to radiate respect and interest. >> Sorry,
I wasn't
Jesus. I wasn't saying that.
I was saying I was reading a chat message. Somebody else said
it. Yeah. in people who disagree with you and people you've come
to feel far away from. It is the building of genuine relationships
in politics,
not the taking of positions. That is truly hard.
But that's also the part that is beautiful.
It's a privilege to do that work, not a concession.
We are more able to admit complexity and extend generosity when
we see others as part of our community.
Working to widen that circle of empathy, to widen our circle
of belonging is both morally and politically good. Whatever the
problems are on the left, there is something truly frightening
brewing on the right. >> Putting aside the tribal >> Okay.
Thank you. Okay. All right. He's going to pull up the the gripers.
This is where like the gropers sort of derail his entire conversation
for me because to me it's like, oh, the right is ascendant right
now. They're overstepping, but they're ascendant in a lot of
ways. And how do you explain the grouper success and they're
forcing their way into a national conversation >> just
for the corporate interest? That's absolutely the case and that's
the only way the country is going to stay >> Exactly. That's
my concern. >> And I absolutely agree with you. I would
say though that
the main challenge to that, a big challenge to that is organized
in America. Paul Gracia, president.
>> Dude, I uh just saying the words there is a lot. I was
thinking about this. I feel like there are certain people
there are certain people who joined up with Israel after October
7th to like produce propaganda. Brianna Woo being one of them.
And I almost feel like they did it from like an anti-semitic
place. Like they didn't look at any of the actual facts on the
ground. They didn't look at how things were going. They just
joined up cuz they were like, "Oh, the always win." Yeah, they're
going to win. Do you know what I mean? Like they could never
defend why they were on that side like entirely. They were just
like, "Well, the the always win. I'll Yeah, I'll I'll go on their
I'll go on their side. They always win." Like,
uh
I I swear to God, that's how I that's how I conceive of it. Like
what they thought in their minds was just like, "Yeah, they control.
Yeah, of course they'll take money from you to it's like, dude,
just look at cuz [clears throat] somebody said Brianna Woo ruined
her career." And I was like, "Yeah, shilling for Israel when
it made no sense to like switch on the Israel issue as they start
really truly committing like a genocide and ethnic cleansing.
That's insane." And it was just like, "Hey, I really think uh
I really think, you know, Israel seems like the good guy now.
I I think now I'm suddenly on Israel's side." Donald Trump's
nominee to lead the office of special counsel, not a small job,
said on a text thread leaked to Politico that he had a quote
streak. A separate text thread of young Republican leaders leaked
to Politico had messages about sending enemies to the gas chambers
and one saying quote I love
people are taking this seriously. This is like the idea of like
locker room talk. I think people way overplay like how bad this
is. It's more the way I look at this is you're literally like
imagine going to the locker room and still yapping your trap
if there was a audio recorder in there or something, right? Like
you literally know that this is all being recorded. These people
are too dumb to be involved in politics, but it's like some talk
in a group chat. It's like way different than
it's way way different than just locker room or sorry, it's way
way different than truly held beliefs.
And Gracia had to withdraw his nomination.
But Vice President JD Vance has dismissed coverage of the young
Republicans messages as pearl clutching. >> And I really
don't want us to grow up in a country where a kid telling a stupid
joke, telling a very offensive stupid joke is caused to ruin
their lives. >> Look, I don't want to ruin anybody's life
either, but these were recent statements by adults who were vying
for leadership in >> Yeah, these guys really weren't kids.
Wasn't one of them, wasn't it? Young Republicans are like up
to 35 and a couple of them were like 34. >> Political organizations
with official ties to the Republican party. >> I thought
almost all of them. >> There's no rule of civic generosity
or political practice that Trumpism has not broken.
And for many I know on the left it's created a sense that there
is no sense in trying to appeal to the median voter.
No sense in moderation. No sense in any of the old rules of politics.
I think what you need to do if you're a part of the Democratic
party is admit that everybody got to go. Okay? You need to have
like a truly cataclysmic
night of long knives for the Democratic party where everybody
was involved in the bad decisions from the past like five, six
years, they all go, right? All of them are out. I think that
that is another massive issue with the Democratic party is they're
running a bunch of Republicans who are who are populists, right?
Okay. It's a it's a joke. It's a joke. It's a joke.
um you're running a bunch of populists, right, who are new. They've
come in very recently. They're not they're not the the Republicans
have had way more and I I'm saying this without actually knowing.
It seems to me like the Republicans have had way more turnover.
Not just from like new people running and getting elected, but
a lot of people with old the older values of the Republicans
just left, right? I think of Trey Gaudy. I think of uh
uh Paul Paul Paul Paul Ryan. Yeah. I think of those two just
leaving because they felt like the values weren't there. Like
they they didn't agree with the where the party was going. Romney
left. Yeah. Like a whole bunch of people just left.
So,
so what I'm saying is you can hold the decisions of the Democrats
against them for a long period of time, right? And that was maybe
the thing that hurt Kamla the most was that she just had a record
from before from pre-Trump, right? Not even pre-Trump, but like
during co she had the most liberal, most progressive voting record,
right? And it could be held against her. That's maybe the biggest
issue is the Democrats maintain a ton of their baggage and the
Republicans have it. The Republicans are new. I find that happens
on the internet too, like with a lot of creators. Like it seems
like with the internet with like a logging, keeping track of
everything somebody does, it only takes so long before you can
just write an effective narrative against that person, right?
And until people figure out how to deal with that, and I'm not
sure how they will or if they will, it seems like turnover is
a pretty big key of
of just like making the whole machine work. So, you can't even
have that much opposition or you can't even have you can't have
like tangible political actions to hold against somebody. I don't
know. That's that's like kind of how I'm looking at it or feeling
about it right now.
Look at how extreme the right has become.
Yet, they have thrived. In this telling, Trump understands what
the Democrats don't. Nothing matters anymore except attention.
But a few things >> uh sorry, her track record was the
thing used against her only mute. You're just wrong. Um the literally
the trans stuff was used against her repeatedly. It's the most
effective ads in some of the key states, right? You're just wrong
on >> Things are wrong with that. >> Trump did moderate
the Republican party in crucial areas. Medicare, Social Security,
trade, and the simple truth. What? What?
>> Party in crucial areas, Medicare, Social Security, trade,
and he moderated the Republican party on trade.
He moderated the Republic. That's a rough one.
I don't know what he means. That can't be tariffs, right?
>> And the simple truth party understands >> Listen,
listen, listen. Democrats don't. Nothing matters anymore except
But a few things are wrong with that. Trump did moderate the
Republican party in crucial areas. Medicare, Social Security,
trade. And
Trump did moderate the Republican party in terms of trade. Moderate
is not moved to the more popular position. If the most popular
position on immigration is cutting the heads off of immigrants,
that's not moderating the position
in my opinion. Uh especially if one side is like, "Don't cut
the heads off of the immigrants." And the other side's like,
"No, absolutely cut the head off of the immigrants." That's not
moderating to go, "Oh, I'm going to cut the heads off. Yeah,
we'll cut the heads off." >> And the simple truth is Democrats
can't win the way Trump. >> Okay. I don't think this is
correct. It's just like totally illogical to say it this way.
>> And the Republicans do. Trump and the Republicans lead
a coalition built on overwhelming strength in rural counties.
America's placebased politics gives rural places disproportionate
political power. Trump and Republicans can hold power with a
smaller coalition than Democrats can.
And then there's this. Democrats shouldn't want to win the way
Republicans do. This country could break.
The abyss is dark and it is deep. And America, like other countries,
>> this guy just totally failed to convince me of any of
his ideas. And now he's hitting me with the emotional plea. >> Has
fallen into it before and can again.
I see the simple fact of a free and fair politics as much more
of an achievement,
something much more precious and difficult to preserve.
I no longer take it or the habits of citizenship or politics
that preserve it for granted. We cannot trust that providence
or some innate American exceptionalism
protects us from calamity. It doesn't. Over the past year, I
have found myself obsessively reading histories of liberalism,
looking for something, even though I didn't know exactly what
Iliberalism is winning right now.
But there's nothing unusual about that. By modern standards,
virtually every past society was illiberal. That we now call
them illiberal. That exclusion and domination and state suppression
have been made strange enough to demand a label. That is the
unlikely achievement.
But how did liberalism do it? For most of my life, when I called
myself a liberal, I meant basically someone who believed in universal
healthcare and the right to form a union and racial equality
and social security.
For most of my life, I just totally misused the term liberal.
>> But in its oldest forms, liberalism was built on a virtue
that we rarely talk about today.
To the ancient Romans, being free required more than a republican
constitution. It also required citizens who practice liberalas
which referred to a noble and generous way of thinking and acting
towards one's fellow citizens.
The word liberalas became liberality.
Liberality proposed, it demanded a different way of relating
across disagreement and division. It flowered into religious
tolerance. When that idea was truly radical,
it built towards liberalism's great insight. Liberalism's first
idea,
conflict of interest and beliefs, was to the liberal mind inescapable.
If tamed and turned to competition in a stable political order,
conflict could nevertheless bear fruit as argument,
experiment, and exchange.
Today, finding ways to turn our disagreements into exchange,
into something fruitful rather than something destructive
seems almost fanciful.
Okay. So with this, oh the way of of, you know, liberalism's
greatest strength is that it turns, you know, arguments into
positive things. Okay. Now you've just come back to the social
media problem. So fix the social media problem. Like you you've
literally now you Okay. Yes. Social media monetizes. It absolutely
maximizes like social conflict and not in a way that can be resolved.
Not in a way that is ever rewarded uh that ever rewards resolving
it honestly and intellect like intellectually honestly right
it's all about hey I believe this I want my side to win I'm going
to amplify whoever helps my side win so now solve all you got
to do is solve the social media issue
solve like the echo chamber issue the social media problem that's
all you got to do man
that's all I he just he just did a whole video to go guys uh
the only problem we have to solve is uh like social media
and the way that human nature seems to amplify the most com the
most uh what would you say the most inflammatory ideas the most
inflammatory people so solve human nature in some ways
great
fantastic contribution I saw a poll a few weeks ago that struck
me it asked Americans what they thought the top problem facing
the country was number one was the economy is what I expected
but number two wasn't immigration or inflation or democracy.
>> Number two is
Oh man, what would number two be? I actually Donald Trump >> can't
think of it. >> It was political division.
>> In that same poll, 64% of the country said they think
we're [snorts] too divided to solve our problems anymore. They're
not wrong. Right now, the project of America feels to many impossible.
And not just on the left. I hear it every time JD Vance or Steven
Miller speaks. I hear it when Trump >> "I hate my opponent
and I don't want the best for them. I'm >> When I hear
that, I hear something scary,
but I also hear an opening, an
I keep coming back to something Craig writes. The moral consensus
of a free state is not something mysteriously prior to or above
politics.
It is the activity, the civilizing activity
of politics itself,
something to be valued almost as a pearl beyond price.
In America, for all our sins, our injustice, our oppression,
a freer state emerged through the practice of >> Why do
you have to be such an can you chill, bro? Ezra is single-handedly
making me believe that not so Erdite could have a actually have
a career in US politics. Jesus >> politics.
It did not do so painlessly.
It did not do so bloodlessly, but it did happen. And for a time,
it gave us confidence in ourselves and in our
It showed what could emerge from genuine relationships between
people who are genuinely other people.
And I think it still could again, >> guys. I think things
could be better.
I I thought I thought this was going to be a video. This is how
Democrats win. He basically gives a strategy. No proof that it
could work. Like no reason to think, no reason to look at it
and go, "Okay, here's how it's different from the Republicans
and here's why I think it'll work over what the Republicans are
doing. Literally
further further pushes in the direction that some people argue
we're losing because of, you know, we go broader
I don't know, man.
I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. Oh, I don't know. Ah,
what a video. What a video. I don't know. I'm going to have to
listen some more and and think about this. I think there are
like some better ways where he describes like big tents. I feel
like if you reward that and lie
because the honest to god truth is you should just lie in some
of those red states and say in like their big issues that you
would disagree with them. You should just lie.
Just run politics on lying, right? That that's really what it
should be is just lie and say you're pro-life.
Say you're pro- life and you're running as Democrat because there
are other things that matter to you. But just say you're pro-life
and like you won't vote for a prochoice. Check the comments.
Okay. Ezra sound engineer. How much bass you want on that mic?
Yes. Okay. This loses the fact that Dems don't really have a
brand right now, which leaves it open for the GOP to paint it
as they want. You know what the solution is to that? not picking
a direction and just letting the GOP paint them as their most
extreme people already. Right?
So he says, "Oh, it's good that we have AOC and and uh M Donnie
as a part of the party." Why? Like I don't I don't even think
he believes that because realistically you're concerned about
how primary challengers message against your own candidates.
Okay. What about the actual election? If the if that if messaging
against somebody on Donald Trump is effective in the primary,
if that's an issue that's that matters to voters, why wouldn't
it work for the opposition going the opposite way in the
right?
Or, you know, pointing out that like the progressives, let's
say your your progressive wins and they just go, "Oh, that guy's
like a communist."
And the guy who was successful, like that's that's the downside
that Ezra's pointing to in primary, right? Then if the moderate
wins, it's like, "Oh, you're in a party with uh like Zor Mani
and AOC. They're trying to pass the most ludicrous and then it's
used against you anyway." So like I I don't even know how he
could believe this.
But hey, it's like the Republicans by having a smaller coalition,
they have like less attack surfaces, right? they have less less
exposure to
and
and like that helps them in a in a world where it's only negative
political attacks. Having more positions represented by your
party just gives more ways for the opponent. Like if you think
in terms of what used to be political correctness or how politicians
used to message when they weren't online all the time, they just
wouldn't really comment in a way on any issue that offended voters.
They'd find the least offensive positions to take, right? But
he's saying, "Oh, you should have all of the people." So, there's
always somebody in your party who can have the offensive position
that the other side can market on,
which I don't know if that I don't know if that works.
I don't know.
I probably have to think more deeply about it. Not be not be
on so little sleep or something. Maybe it'll make more sense
to me at another point.
All right,
with that said, guys, I think you know we did Oh, hold on. We'll
do Zoran update real quick. We'll do the Zoran update real quick.
Um, I I just I don't know. The dates got away from me, guys.
Okay. My landlord messaged me today and was like, "Why haven't
you paid rent yet? What the [__] are you doing?"
It's like, "Oh, I've like I've lived in the same place for a
long time." Uh, like a couple years now, and I've I've like never
missed rent by more than a day. Like, sometimes it'll be afternoon
on the first of the month that I'll pay rent. But otherwise,
it's like pretty consistently the last day of the month. You're
still renting? Yeah,
I rent like an apartment. Got a really good deal. Anyway, no
autodraft. I should just have it on auto, but yeah, he was like
to me.
because I just I I don't know. I lost track of the days somehow.
Goofy. This was the last poll I saw. Was this Atlas Intel Mumani
plus 7 is the last poll I saw. Mani + 7. Now, I saw Slime say
that I was lying and the polling wasn't shifting or wasn't closing
at all, but Mannani plus 7 seems pretty rough. No. What's a good
deal? Uh$,650.
It's It's uh Yeah, probably shouldn't say more than that. It's
just That's how much it was. That's how much it is. All right.
Anyway, where's Slime? Slime told me I was wrong about the polling
here. Where'd you go, Slime?
Where'd you go? Where'd you go? He left. He ran away. Oh well.
Yeah. So, this one seemed concerning. Somebody said something
about the the I guess whoever fills these out. We could look
at the cross tabs. see if this is like overly weighted towards
older people.
But I do think it's interesting that it's narrowing. I think
everybody's bringing everything to bear against Zoron. It's very
interesting. Okay. I think everything's coming to bear against
Zoron. And I wanted to watch two quick videos. One is him responding
to stuff on MSNBC from earlier today. We'll pull this up and
then I'm going to look at another thing
>> analyzing uh I'm going to look at another video analyzing
his polls. >> Okay. Okay, so we're going to watch these
two videos and then we'll probably move into drama stuff. Some
drama stuff and then we'll go over to Spooky Sunday right after.
>> I'm sorry that it's not in person, but I look forward
to that being the next >> Well, it's a busy day as we know
in in New York, not just for you because it's the last day of
voting, but it is the New York City Marathon, which you were
running in uh last year. It's always an exciting day for us.
Um, it's one of the things when you look at the marathon when
you're up on the Upper West Side and you see all the the the
runners uh closing in, what you realize is although the world
is running in this marathon, it's a real snapshot into how diverse
this city is. And the topic of diversity has come up a few times
in the past week, your opponent Andrew Cuomo was on this network
yesterday morning with my colleagues on the weekend and he said,
quote, "Our diversity is our strength, but it can also be a weakness."
Uh last Wednesday on a podcast, Vice President JD Vance said
that it's totally reasonable and acceptable uh for Americans
to want to live next to people with whom they have a commonality
like people who speak the same language as them. You come from
one of the most diverse parts of New York City. What's your what's
your take on this? >> Well, I think first when Andrew Cuomo
uh turnup I don't know if that's necessarily true.
If he's splitting votes with SE while going into the election,
that could be true. SL is probably going to keep
I do think some of the SEO voters would go towards Zoron if they
weren't voting. Sua though >> said that diversity is a
weakness. He also then misidentified which black host he was
speaking to on this very network. And we're seeing not only is
he Donald Trump's puppet, but he's starting to also become Donald
Trump's parrot because we're hearing the very same kind of language
of hate and division coming from him in his final acts in public
life out of a desperation and an understanding that the only
thing that he's actually cared about all these years, power,
is actually slipping away from him. And to hear this from the
vice president, it just completely reveals what the Republican
party has to offer Americans in this time. The issue is not what
language Americans are speaking at the dinner table. It's that
they can't afford to put food on it. And I'm proud to be running
a campaign that recognizes the belonging of each and every New
Yorker, no matter where they were born or when they got here.
And >> did Stardust misread the fact that I was defending
her? She got like really mad. Hold on. She like misread and think
I was getting mad at her.
Literally defending her.
She quoted this and said, "Fuck off, fatty. Rude." Okay, rude.
Hold on. Where is it? Oh, maybe she replied.
Yeah, she's like mad. It's like literally I'm on your side. I
called this other person stupid. I Is she Did she misread?
Do you think she misread? No, I'm not going to do it. I thought
about doing it for a second. I'm not >> looking to make
the most expensive city in the United States of America affordable
for all. >> Speaking about language, uh on Vance's comments
about stirring up concerns about people who don't speak the same
language. This is not a fear that you have. I I was not clear
on how many languages you seem to be able to speak, but you made
some campaign videos in a few different languages. I just want
to have my viewers listen to a couple of
>> All right, I'm taking off Spanish and Arabic there.
Uh, what else do you speak? And and again, in a world where people
are sort of saying diversity is our problem and you're too diverse
and you're Muslim and this and that, you're you're fully leaning
into this on your social media that not only do you like diversity,
but you you practice it. >> You Okay. Yeah. And I think
it's what it means to be a New Yorker. Look, >> I don't
think I don't think speaking a second language is practicing
diversity. I don't >> I speak English and I speak Hindi,
but as you can see, I will try very hard to learn enough of a
language to make a video. And there's a reason some of those
videos start in the daytime and end in the night. And there's
a reason some of those >> Bro, I'm sorry. That's like that's
not practicing diversity. That's just >> Cuts are very
very quick. It's because it takes quite a bit of work.
>> What's the point? What's the point to New Yorkers? You're
not you're not hiding who you are or the fact that you you love
the diversity of this city in this country.
>> Yeah, I think the point is understanding what makes
New York City such a special place. This is a city of the world.
I am representing Queens right now in the state legislature and
it's called the world's burrow and part of that, as you said,
is a reflection of the fact that it's one of the most diverse
counties in the entire country. And for so long when people have
run for office, they have gone to political consultants and asked
them which voters they should focus on. And we wanted to reject
that assessment that there was a set of New Yorkers you could
leave out on the basis of their voting propensity or on the basis
of the languages that they speak. And we wanted to make sure
that we brought our political case to each and every person that
called the city home. And what we're finding is that when you
treat New Yorkers, no matter how often they voted or whether
they voted at all, with the respect and dignity that they deserve,
they will respond in kind. Whether that is speaking about young
people, whether that's speaking about immigrant voters, whomever,
you know, the Andrew Cuomo of the world like to overlook, those
are the very >> uh hold on. Is this this food shops person
just post this? Why why isn't this popping up in my notifications?
I just got a notification.
>> Why is it not popping up? >> Hello. Oh, did it
go away? What the Okay, I guess it went away. I thought I had
a food shops post her responding to the substance tweet. Did
Did she not respond to substance tweet? Hold on. Uh not these
ones. Just a second, dude. I thought she responded to some substance
tweet just now. I got the alert on my phone. Did it go away?
This one.
Hold on. Yeah, if I apply the same standard to JTO or that JT
applies to Hutch, then I can easily associate all of the Destiny
antifans to Kiwi farms and doxing and life ruination tactics.
Therefore, using his framework, I can justify defensive doxing.
Doxing based on ruining someone's career. Does she want to go
ahead and do that? And
my my whole point was if you believe something with absolutely
no evidence, right? If you repeat something with no evidence
and it comes from a very specific source, like some sort of cult,
then you can probably assume the person repeating it is from
that cult. If it cannot be substantiated at all, then it's probably
from a cult. Yeah, I realize that she's
I I just figure maybe she'll just like go ahead and and explain
how that works cuz like
the implication there would be that I'm saying things about Destiny
that have like absolutely no evidence for them. I don't believe
that to be the case. So
anyway, we can continue. Let's continue with the video. >> Can
also be at the heart of our democratic process. I had Brad Lander
on the show yesterday. You and Brad Lander
think she has brain cells to explain anything. Uh, no. Which
is why it's funny to quote or to reply
>> to each other. Uh, and and he's out there as a surrogate
for you. Uh, let's talk about the the continued allegations of
anti-semitism
against you. What do you say to
a New York voter who's watching this right now who has heard
through social media or various articles or ads that that you're
anti-semitic? I think first what I would say is that there's
no room for anti-semitism in this city and it's a scourge that
I would root out of the five burrows as someone who will be leading
the entirety of the city and I lead the city not just to lead
New Yorkers who vote for me but frankly any New Yorker and any
New Yorker who calls the city home and a few weeks ago I was
on the M57 which in case you're wondering is the slowest bus
in New York City traveling at an average speed of 4.9 m an hour
and seated right next to me was a speech therapist who introduced
herself to me as a New Yorker. She told me that her daughter
is a big fan and she phone banks from college and she said that
she herself was less sure about our campaign. And so we started
to speak and she asked me, you know, about my thoughts on Israel
and Palestine. She asked me about my thoughts on anti-semitism
here in New York City. And she also shared with me an anecdote
of where she's trying to sell her apartment and her realtor came
over, looked at the books on her bookshelf and said, "Take the
books off." And I told her that that was unacceptable because
this is a city that we're looking to do more than just protect
New Yorkers, but a city where we're looking to celebrate and
cherish those New Yorkers. And I've made clear my thoughts on
Israel and Palestine. And I'm also running to be the leader of
this city. And that means leading everyone, no matter their opinions
on that subject or any subject, to ensure that this is a city
that they can see themselves in, whether in my city hall or in
the city that they call home. >> One of the top slogans,
>> the polls narrowed, it was just one Atlas Intel poll
at the end here was him plus seven. Joe Cuomo up slightly, 34,
him at 41, Curtis Lewa picking up. Now, SEA picking up, you know,
you'd assume this skews more like in a Republican leaning, right?
Like if we looked at the cross tabs here, you'd expect to see
like old white voters maybe going more towards SEWA,
>> but promises of your campaign is to freeze the rent.
Now, there some things you've you've promised your campaign that
you don't have direct control over, but this is one of them that
you do. Uh this would affect roughly 1 million rentstabilized
units in the city. that's overseen by something called the Rent
Guidelines Board, which you would you would have oversight over
as mayor. Uh roughly 2 million tenants overall. Now, if you succeed
with that freeze, what would the effect be? Obviously, we know
what they'd be on those 2 million tenants, those those 1.1 million
uh properties, what would it be on everybody else? Because there
are a lot of people who are not in rent stabilized places in
New York who still pay 40, 50, 60% of their income on on housing.
This would be one part of a larger housing agenda which in its
totality speaks to all eight and a half million people who call
the city home. And for the about half of all tenants who live
in Mark, >> just want to point out um I feel like this
person is now going to take like a bunch of time to go and write
out a response,
right? I feel like I feel like I asked a pretty simple question.
We'll see how long it takes them to lay out a response, right?
If it takes them like hours to lay out a response, I'll assume
they they couldn't do what they said just quite so easily. I
don't know what the response could possibly be.
They take a shower to brainstorm. I just I feel like the response
should be pretty easy, right? But maybe not. I don't know. I
assume they'll answer quickly or else it seems like it would
be quite difficult. market rate units as you're describing facing
these skyrocketing rents. We would also be building 200,000 new
affordable homes over the next 10 years from the public sector
and also making it easier for the private sector to build more
housing because one of the key parts of the housing crisis that
we're facing in New York City is that of a crisis of supply,
a crisis of production. And we have to make that crisis come
to an end by learning the lessons we've seen in Jersey City where
for every thousand people they're building seven homes. Here
in New York City, we're struggling for four, while Tokyo is already
at 10. And this is an example of how for a long time, politicians
have taken a language of New York exceptionalism to justify mediocrity
in this city. And it's time to actually deliver excellence and
efficiency at the heart of a public sector that we care deeply
about. >> We're talking about your social media reach,
the fact that you do a lot of social media. You get out there,
you've got a particularly young audience, the type of audience
who may not be watching us right now. Um, but there's a lot of
money going into traditional media in this race. Uh the most
prominent of the groups that are raising money for this is a
group called Fix the City. It's raised more than $35 million.
Two others have raised 2.5 million and 1.5 million uh respectively.
Some of the donors include Michael Bloomberg. He's given uh almost
$10 million since before the primary, members of the Lauder family,
uh the hedge fund executive Bill Aman, the hotel and casino magnet.
Um Steve Wyn,
many of these groups are supporting Andrew Cuomo. How do you
explain that to to New York voters? How do you what what connections
do you draw between the donors and and Cuomo's campaign? >> I
think Bill >> Wait, I thought Atlas Intel was the most
was the highest quality poll from the presidential election.
I thought they're like an A+ poller on 538.
Am I crazy? I thought Atlas Intel was actually like a quite an
accurate
may be under the misapprehension that for every strongly worded
tweet he sends out, he has to donate another $100,000 to Andrew
Cuomo's super PAC. >> Oh, sorry. I [__] I misread
your I misread your message, Shhatty Nickel. You said they were
a very accurate poller, not they weren't. >> I think largely
what you see with these kinds of donors and these kinds of donations
is a desire to keep a system that has been rigged to benefit
the very few in this city at the expense of the very many. And
I understand why they would be concerned at the prospect of Andrew
Cuomo losing this race because it's not just him as an individual.
It's also his style of politics where access and influence can
be bought. And I'm proud to be here sitting in front of you as
the Democratic nominee. Not by virtue of the donations we've
received, though we did max out the public matching funds here
in New York City, but by virtue of the volunteer team that we
have built of now more than 100,000 volunteers who today are
on the precipice of breaking a New York state record for most
doors knocked in a 24-hour period. And that's what this campaign
really is about. It's about bringing democracy back to working
>> Let's talk about that most doors knocked. You're you're
you're looking to break uh 200,000
not break. You don't want to break the doors. you want to knock
on 200,000 doors today and and break a record. Uh talk to me
about this because you have tens of thousands of volunteers.
You have more volunteers than many people have voters. >> Yes.
It's it's it's truly one of the honors of of this campaign is
to lead now more than 100,000 volunteers. And what we've seen
in these volunteers is that they make the difference. Because
for all of the money that is spent on ads and on a smear and
slander campaign, for many New Yorkers, the moment that will
actually open their eyes as to what's actually on the ballot
is when they have a conversation with another New Yorker. And
that comes from a conversation at their doorstep. It comes from
a conversation on the phone. It might even come from a conversation
as they're waiting for the train, which Andrew Cuomo defunded
when he was the governor of New York State. And what we found
is that in these conversations, it can get back to the heart
of what this race should be about, which is cost of living. And
so often that's been pushed to the side because other candidates
don't actually have a plan to address it. And you know, as much
as you and I may be living and breathing this race as many as
as well as many other New Yorkers, there are many other of our
neighbors across these five burrows for whom the struggle to
afford this city is so difficult that tuning into politics is
something that happens in the final days. And I actually had
a friend of mine, Charlie, who went and knocked on some doors
in Hell's Kitchen a few days ago. And afterwards, he shared that
he spoke to a man who had not heard of me as yet. He had not
heard of what was happening in this race. And that conversation
was what inspired him to take another look. And that's the way
that we're going to win this race on >> One of the things
that that somebody said to me the other day is, "I can't believe
I've got a vote for uh for Andrew Cuomo, but I just don't think
Mani's got the experience. He's he's young." He didn't have a
beef with you and your views and your energy. He said, "Can he
This is one of the biggest political jobs in the world." I mean,
probably the second hardest in America. >> It is an incredibly
difficult job. It's also an incredible opportunity to serve the
people of the city. And I'm proud of my record as a state assembly
member of someone who won close to half a billion dollars in
debt relief for thousands of working-class taxi drivers, who
won the first free buses in New York City history, and stopped
a frack gas power plant from being built in Queens. And I'll
also be prouder still of assembling a team around me that has
experience that spans generations and a number of mayoral administrations
because New Yorkers deserve to have the best and the brightest
serving them in city hall, not a collection of examples of patronage
politics that we've seen under this current administration.
>> This guy kind of [laughter]
uh I'm not a huge fan to be honest with you of this interview.
It seems like very pandery.
I'm sure it's going to be fine. He's like quite far ahead. Uh,
I like the idea of this guy. I I've never really listened to
him speak for very long. I should have watched the Merryill debates.
Not not like a massive fan to be honest with you, but I've heard
maybe this just isn't a great interview. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It is what it is. I think there's a there's
one more video I'm pulling that I think is going to be better
cuz he's not in it. So, give me a
joining me here at the Magic Wall CN. You have 10 minutes on
this video where things stand on this video real quick and then
I'm I'm on to drama stuff. >> You know what the polls say,
but what does the early vote tell us? >> So, specifically
in New York City, this is a poll result from Quinn Quinnipak
University last week. I want to show you why when I look at the
early vote right now, looking at age breakdown, the early vote
here in this Quinnipak poll, you see that Manny wallops Cuomo
with younger voters, 18 to 34 year olds. uh voters above 50,
you see that it's a slight Cuomo advantage, a six-point advantage.
So, obviously that's a narrow advantage, Manu, but there are
a lot more of these voters than there are of these voters, which
is what gives the Cuomo world belief that they might have a path
here. Um, take a look at the early voting numbers. So this is
among registered Democrats, which by the way, the vast majority
of New York City voters are uh uh voters 18 to 29 in the early
vote to date, which by the way ends today, 16% of the electorate,
early voting electorate is 18 to 29. 51% of the early voting
electorate is 50 above. Again, that disparity is what is giving
the Cuomo campaign some belief that they're turning out their
voters. I will note over the time of the last week, uh it has
been getting a little younger. This isn't quite as young as the
elector it was in the Democratic primary. Uh >> but you
I thought all early voting skews older. No >> catapulted
Mandani's victory. But it is still a far younger electorate than
we saw four years ago in New York City. When it comes to New
Jersey in the early vote, take a look at the partisan breakdown
rather than the age breakdown. 52% of early voters in New Jersey
are Democrats. 29% are Republicans. That's a big hole for Chitterelli
to dig out of. In fact, Cheryl is more on track when you look
at the partisansship of the early vote than Harris was a year
ago in the presidential when she still won the state uh by six
points. >> That's so interesting. And you know, Democrats
tend to do better in early voting as well. And you tell you could
tell us a lot Tuesday can also give us some indication about
whether Democrats have done a better job of winning back some
of those voters. They lost to Donald Trump in the last cycle.
Trump made inroads with people of color in particular. talk about
that and New Jersey in particular where Democrats are focusing
in these final days. >> Yeah, I mean I think this is why
we saw Barack Obama where we saw him yesterday. I mean he was
here in County, New Jersey, home to Newark. Okay.
I'm like dying. I got to get on to something that's not politics.
I I can do politics stuff when I'm like awake, but I I got to
move on. Okay. All right. We'll not move on that far. Although
we could we could go straight on to the chank stuff. I think
I'm going to switch over to kick only for the rest of the stream,
guys. So, if you guys are watching on Twitch, we're going to
head over to kick. All right,
If somebody wants to throw that in the Twitch chat, kick.com/jdlk.
We're going to go there for the rest of the stream.
Do the Hassan ad. Okay, real quick for the Twitch viewers, while
you load up the while you load up the kick stream, we're going
to watch this
this Quomo Hassan ad. Give me a second. >> Deserve 911,
dude. That Zoron's >> Zoro Mdani is wrong for New York
City. >> America deserve 911, dude. >> That's Zoron's
buddy on.
>> Oh, hold on.
>> Uh, is that Chatty Nickel? Yeah, Chatty Nickel. Thank
you for the gifted sub. Appreciate it, dude. >> They're
saying we deserve 911. It's a disgrace to every life lost. Zoron
went on Piker's show and now [__] was just spotted
at Zoron's event. Mom Donnie is wrong for New York. Paid for
by
He doesn't even live here.
It sometimes feels like they just gave up on beating Zoron and
the next best thing they could do is attack a random guy they
read too many profiles of. Dude, this guy this guy shook Hassan's
hand. Absolutely disgusting. All New Yorkers are compelled by
law to spit on Hassan [__] whenever they see him.
Okay, that's actually I lied. That's actually a part of Andrew
Cuomo's campaign. By law, you must spit on Hassan [__]
if you see him in the streets. Okay, by law. All right, I'm going
to close this up. Okay, if you guys aren't over there, good luck.
We're heading over to kick only for the rest of the stream. Have
a good Have a good time, guys. Bye-bye on Twitch. Oh boy. Here
we go. Here we go. All right, I think I want to do the the chank
debate. We didn't get a chance to do it before. This is the full
the full Steven Miller debate. Okay. Jillian Michaels talking
about Mdani. Randy Fine wants mom Donnie
>> Deported. Okay. What did he want for Tucker? He definitely
he called Tucker Carlson the most dangerous anti-semite in America.
no longer at the gate. They are now inside. >> So you're
calling Center a barbarian? Well, given he's here, let me bring
him >> There are barbarians inside the gate. And that's
Randy Fine. Randy Fine is a sick terrorist sympathizer. >> You
want him deported. Is that right? >> I do. And look, I
think Mami lied in his naturalization application. >> He's
a dirty Muslim and you should hate him for supporting Muslim.
And that's what almost all of the Israeli supporters are doing.
>> Dude, just come out and condemn.
It's not that hard. The anti-semitic attacks that is so permeating
on CNN. Dude, did did Chank go in like 4v1
just power bomb all of these people? Is that what happened? Did
they bring every every Zionist they could they brought against
Chank and it wasn't enough? This is so ridiculous. Somebody criticizing
you. >> Oh, never mind. This guy's here. This Omar guy.
Okay, never mind. No, he had a tag team partner. It's not as
bad. I thought it was like him versus everyone else. An >> anti-semitic
attack. If somebody says that you are lying, that is not an attack
on that is an attack on you. >> Piers, I'm going to be
done with this. if you're going to allow racist and bigoted attacks
against one of your
>> Zoran Mandani says that Islamophobia is endemic in the
United States and his opponents have given him ample reason to
make that case. A New York congresswoman called him the jihadist
candidate for mayor. Republican Randy Fine is trying to have
him deported. Mandan's main opponent, Andrew Cuomo, has called
him a terrorist sympathizer and was widely criticized for saying
this in a recent interview. Why did he go?
>> Bro,
people are so lazy now. They can't even just say about Hassan.
They have to go, "Oh, Hassan like shook this guy's hand." That
makes this guy a terrorist sympathizer, too. Hassan is a terrorist
sympathizer and Mani shook his hand. Easy. Easy. >> God
forbid another 911. Can you imagine Mandami in the seat?
>> Manny 911. 911. Mani Mani 911. Mdani 911. 911. Mdani.
He he he'd be cheering.
>> It's another problem, >> dude. That Okay, bro.
They're just They're pulling out the old timey racism. God damn.
>> For his part, man. >> That's like way more overt
than I expected. I Dude, Andrew Cuomo is a seasoned politician.
What the is he >> Die has not always struck the right tone
on issues of race and faith. He previously compared the NYPD
to the Israeli Defense Forces, for example, and he fought back
crocodile tears while talking about some of the real victims
of 9/11. I want to use this moment to speak to the Muslims of
New York City. I want to speak to the memory of my aunt who stopped
taking the subway after September 11th because she did not feel
safe in her hijab. >> Well, M. Darn has now clarified those
remarks, but only to say it wasn't his aunt, but his father's
cousin. All of this has become a matter of national debate for
several reasons. Firstly, the competing accusations of Islamophobia
and anti-semitism have underpinned basically everything since
October the 7th. Second, if Mandani wins in New York, many think
the Democrats will follow his socialist lead. And finally, it
comes at a time of hand ringing and soulsearching over ICE raids,
anti-immigrant rhetoric, and the question of what it means to
be an American. Is Mandani the embodiment of this great colorblind
meritocracy?
>> That's not totally true, Chhatty Nickel. I did hear
him talk about the gifted
to contrast himself against Mandani, but and basically nothing
else, >> or as Randy Fine puts it, part of the invasion.
Well, joining me to debate all of this is the host of Keeping
It Real, Julia Michaels, the former deputy press secretary and
host of the Katie Miller podcast, Katie Miller.
Oh, well, you know what? That makes me feel good. If I if I ever
get invited to Piers Morgan for some reason, I'm not going to
feel like I can't just be Listen, I'm the CEO of Jtock Productions.
Okay, let's go. CEO, president of JSTock Productions, number
one, the number one streaming company on the internet. I don't
know. the founder and CEO of the Young Turks, Chen Yuga, and
the Palestinian
>> American journalist, Omar Bad. Well, welcome to all
of you. Um, Jillian, let me start with you. Welcome back to Uncensored.
You know, I thought it'd be helpful probably to start the debate
about Mandani by reminding us all of some of the more inflammatory
things that he said on his record. Um, in June 2020, he wrote
on X, "We don't need an investigation to know that the NYPD is
racist, anti-quer, and a major threat to public safety. What
we need is to hashdefund
the NYPD. In 2023, he linked the NYPD to the IDF in a Democratic
Socialist of America panel panel discussion, saying, "I think
that for anyone to care about these issues, we have to make them
hyper local. We have to make it clear that when the boot of the
NYPD is on your neck, it's been laced by the IDF." In June, he
declined to condemn the phrase globalizing in Tifard, instead
saying that's not language I use, and he would discourage the
use of it. In September when asked if he agreed with the Israeli
prime minister stance that is a terrorist group that needs to
be destroyed. Manny said I'm not going to echo the words of Benjamin
Netanyahu. Um when you take it in totality I can see why uh people
have got exercised about this albeit with the last two you know
a failure to do something is not quite the same as endorsing
it and we should be uh that should be recorded. But what what
is your view about Mandani?
Well, the one thing that I would hope people stop doing is pointing
out that he's Muslim because honestly, who cares. What does that
have to do with anything regarding his policies and how he will
run New York City? So, that should be called out from the get.
It's wrong. Nobody should do it. Simultaneously, yes, a lot of
the things you said are alarming to me. I do wish like, dude,
just come out and condemn.
It's not that hard. It's very common sense in my opinion. What's
alarming to me about mom Donnie are his policies. And if we're
going to talk about that, I feel like I can pontificate on it.
But with regard >> him being Muslim, I go back to again,
who cares? And people should stop calling that out. It's wrong.
>> Okay. So, you
totally denounce Andrew Cuomo. Like, Andrew Cuomo is just running
on that. I don't know. Okay.
>> I guess it's relevant if he is saying that Islamophobia
is endemic in the United States. I mean, do you believe that
it is endemic in the United States? A hatred of people for their
>> There. Hold on a second. I got to I got to reset my
headphones. They're clicking.
Reconnecting. Reconnecting. Reconnecting. Reconnecting. Reconnecting.
Reconnecting.
Reconnecting. There we go. We're back.
>> Oh, not bad. >> Believe that it is endemic in
the United States. The hatred of the people for their Here we
go.
>> Finally. I don't think it's endemic in the United States,
but it does exist. Racism exists. Exists. I don't think it's
endemic. And I think that kind of fear-mongering, rage baiting
is literally tearing us apart, which is why I want to see it
stop when it comes to his rel.
>> Hey, this guy who keeps tying me to 9/11 repeatedly,
I think he's kind of racist. It seems like like anybody who won't
call that out is Islamophobic. It leads me to think it's endemic,
possibly. Uh, that's actually rage bait and you're virtue signaling
and you're gay. Thanks. Thanks, Julian as well. So, listen, he
said a lot of things that I don't like. This is America. He's
allowed to say those things. What I again I go back to what I
wish people would attack him on specifically are his policies
because that's where I believe he has exceptional vulnerability.
Like if you don't like the things that he's saying about Gaza
or or the don't double down by saying those things about him
being Muslim. That that's my >> He's never said anything
about the Jews. We should just be clear about the fact that he's
never said anything about the that's a way that it's just a phrase
that gets imposed on him because we can't find anything >> to
condemn. Yeah. But that's not saying anything about the whatever
his views are on that's a completely different conversation.
We should just use words carefully and and to be like if we're
going to have a constructive discourse, it's important not to
put words in other people's mouths. So anytime you hear Mamani
and you hear the phrase the followed by it, that's typically
a smear because Mamani has never expressed any views that are
anti-semitic. If his political views about Israel and Palestine
are problematic, let's debate the merits of those without suggesting
that he's saying something about the whom he never did. >> Oh,
okay. What >> translation? Hey, how about you stop being
a foul lying and argue some ideas here? Thank you, Mr. Omar.
It's Omar Badar, right? Wow, what a great point. >> I think
that's fair enough, Omar.
>> I was going to say he has a rap song where he celebrates
the Holy Land five >> who, you know, have gone to jail
for sending millions of dollars to How do you think that would
make a person feel? Probably not great.
>> Not great, Jillian. >> Never heard heard that
song. >> Israel slaughters. Hold on. Hold on. I mean, slaughters
our children over and over and over again. And all we do is all
we And peers, this is really important. It's not that the American
people are Islamophobic. They said American media, mainstream
media, and all is almost all the Israeli supporters are the most
bigoted, racist people in the country. They despise Muslims.
All they do is smear Muslims 24/7.
>> Okay. Chank came in. Dude, Omar's like, hey, he didn't
say anything about the That's kind of weird for you to say that.
And she continues to make up. Okay. And then Chen comes in. Every
single Zionist is a disgusting bigot.
I love the energy. every single time >> well pretending
that they're concerned about bigotry but only when it affects
their beloved Israel. So they're like, "Oh my god, I'm so concerned
about anti-semitism. Oh, you said something slightly true, actually
very true about Israel, but it hurt my feelings. YOU'RE AN ANTI-SEMITE.
FIRE THEM, cancel them, etc. This is all thuggery. There's a
bunch of pro-Israeli forces inside America. They've taken over
our Congress. They've taken over mainstream media. And not only
do they try to smear, cancel, fire, and arrest anyone who criticizes
Israel, but on top of that, they now demand that you be racist
and bigoted against Muslims. And and it's so hilarious with your
words because Mi, hold on, let me finish. Hold on. Let me finish.
Let me finish. Let me finish. Let me finish. Let me finish. So,
let me finish. So, now they go, okay, even though Manny has never
said anything anti-Semitic, nothing against you. And even though
the majority of according to polling are supporting Mam Dani,
67% of younger Americans in New York that's under 45 are supporting
Mam Dani. We're going to lie anyway and we're going to say, you
know what, he's a dirty Muslim and you should hate him for supporting
Muslims. And that's what almost all of the Israeli supporters
are doing. Almost all of mainstream media. >> Uh, I don't
really want to play the song. So, you want a gift? It's cool.
down that sick, disgusting Andrew Cuomo who's as bigoted as it
gets.
>> Today's show is sponsored by >> No, don't chill,
Pierce. Just go ahead.
>> Why is it that every time someone wants to criticize
Mammi, it immediately comes back to the Jew and the anti-Israel
movement instead of actually talking about his viewpoints.
That's literally,
dude. Ah, I the the content we thought we were coming for was
uh Chank versus Steven Miller's wife, but the content I'm actually
here for now is watching Omar Badar sit here like, "Is anybody
are these people even capable of listening? Are these people
even capable of hearing the word?" He He comes in, he's like,
"Hey, let's just talk about, you know, his position on Palestine,
but don't pretend he's anti-Semitic or something." And she's
like, "Listen, I just want to talk about the issues here, okay?
I just want to talk about He's just sitting here like, "I'm I'm
here to talk about the issues. Surely you're going to do that,
right? You just talk about the issues, right? Katie Miller, >> immediately
comes back to the and the anti-Israel movement instead of actually
talking about >> So, so what happened? It immediately comes
back to this is that she's saying that as a criticism of Chank
or of Omar when the reason it went there is because Jillian Michaels
took it there and they >> his view points, which is that
>> nobody said, you just said it. You always do that. We
say Israel, you say
>> um yeah, it was sorry, it was your debate partner, the
person on your side of this, Katie Miller, >> Jews, we
say Israel is a government. Please don't make it about Americans
and you come back. >> It's the same thing Omar did. >> Make
it about Americans. WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU? WHAT'S wrong with
you? >> Israel state. Yes or no? >> First of all,
okay, so [laughter] is a Muslim state and you can criticize it
all day long. All day long. I don't There's NO SPECIAL PROTECTION.
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS YOU'RE DECODING LANGUAGE THAT Jewish
state >> say that we should not be here and we should not
be
>> uh I hope should hit her with the hey don't you think
you're kind of painting a target on all backs if you're going
to make being the same as being like Israeli right if you're
going to do that then aren't you saying that and America are
culpable for all of the actions of Israel isn't that a really
dangerous thing to do when it seems like Israel is murdering
thousands of people a month
>> in existence and that you would be happy for other people
like I want ISRAEL TO BE SAFE.
YOU'RE TOTALLY LYING. IT'S very normal for a Miller to be completely
and utterly lying. That's not [laughter] >> lying. Uh accusing
me of lying. That's anti-semitic. You say you say I'm lying because
don't do it. Even for Jews, 1967 borders. But you guys SAY NO
MORE PALESTINIAN LAND. TAKE GAZA. TAKE THE WEST BANK. TAKE SOUTHERN
LEBANON. YOUR GREED knows no bounds. And by the way, YOU AND
YOUR HUSBAND ARE SUPPOSED TO BE >> OKAY, SHANKS. Shank's
getting super close to the line here. Your greed knows no bounds.
[laughter] Chank, she's not Israeli technically, even though
she's a totally a totally like evil person likely if she's married
to Stephen Miller. You You can't Be careful, Chank. Be careful.
You're getting too heated.
>> Take Southern Lebanon. Your greed knows no balance.
AND BY THE WAY, YOU AND YOUR HUSBAND ARE SUPPOSED TO BE WORKING.
>> DUDE, OMAR, SORRY, I have to back it up again. Omar's
sitting here like he's slowly being like, "Dude, Chen, can you
chill? Chen, can you I don't want to be on. Don't put me next
to you. Chank. Chank. Chank. I'm not saying these things. You
got to chill. >> Take southern Lebanon. Your greed knows
no bounds. And by the way, YOU AND YOUR HUSBAND ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE WORKING FOR [laughter] AMERICA, not for Israel. I think
you're betraying this country. >> All right. J, let Katie
Pierce
[laughter] Kat on a quick note. >> Omar Omar. Omar. Omar.
I'll come to you. But let Katie finish her point. Then I'll come
to you. >> No. Pierce. Quite frankly, I'm really sick and
tired of this racist bigoted rhetoric that can comes from people
like you against my husband, against my family, and my children.
I am raising children in this country to this. >> What
a weirdo.
>> Piers, I'm going to be done with this if you're going
to allow racist and bigoted attacks against one of your commentators
just for the sake that he will not >> Casey, to be clear,
Casey, to be clear, >> he inserted a line that says the
Miller line. IS THAT NOT CODED LANGUAGE? FOR THEREFORE, we are
>> Come on, Pierce. Where are you? Where are you? GOD,
YOU'RE SO IF I CAN SPEAK THAT YOU'RE SH MY FIREARM, I'M CANCELLED.
I'M cancelled from America. OH MY GOD. ISRAEL'S FEELINGS HAVE
BEEN HURT. WHY DON'T YOU WORK FOR THIS COUNTRY THIS COUNTRY instead
of >> Can we try? All right. Can we play? All right. Let's
stop the ad homonym attacks. Let's try and get this back to a
more civilized debate, which is actually about the likely incoming
mayor of New York. Katie, I was giving you the chance to respond.
If you want me to do it for you, I'm happy to do that. But normally
in a panel discussion if someone makes I agree and you shouldn't
be interrupted. So Katie let me just ask you separately. Let's
not get into ad hominemum stuff. It's honestly I think the viewers
are sick of it. Let me just ask you let me just ask you Katie.
>> What is your fundamental opposition to Mandani because
my my view of Mandani is he is he's very charismatic. He's a
skillful politician. He has reigned back on some of the more
inflammatory things he undeniably said. The stuff he said about
the NYPD would be for some people disqualifying frankly in a
city like New York. but he's managed to come through that by
reigning back on some of that stuff. Um, and he is, as Czechugo
rightly points out, he has a remarkable popularity with young
New Yorkers. I mean, it is remarkable that for someone who people
have branded anti-semitic,
a lot of New Yorkers simply don't agree. They want to vote for
him. So, he is what he is. I also think, as Jillian pointed out,
that a probably a more uh obvious stick to beat him with politically
are his views, which are pretty socialist. And what is fascinating
about this politically looking at the totality and potentially
a future general election.
>> All right, I'm also uh I'm going I'm going in on on
Twitter a little bit here. I uh threw this one out here. What
is this? I should I just want to hear like how you could use
this lens that I described in the clip.
If I just want to know how that could be applied to tie me to
Kiwi Farms, right? I just I really want to I want to see it.
So, I I threw that in the chat if you guys want to retweet that.
You want to engage with that tweet because I Hey, this person
claim claims to
to be able to apply this to me and and that will tie me to Kiwi
Farms or something cuz she she thinks I'm a Destiny anti.
I just want to see how it could be done. I I want to be taught.
Truly, it's going to happen.
is if you have a progressive socialist like Mandani who wins
in New York, is that the way the Democratic Party is now going
to go and does that have any chance of winning against what would
likely be another MAGA candidate in 2028? So these are big big
picture issues that will come out of a Mandani victory. But from
your perspective, Katie, what is your fundamental opposition
to Manny becoming New York
>> I want to start off with do you agree when your guest
says that the Miller's always lied? because that's what your
guest on your show just said is that the Millers always lie.
And so now I'll continue into saying Montami just as you said
here is a >> Wait, what
do you did he did she just ask if he agrees or
did she even finish >> Your fundamental opposition. >> Hold
on. I need to hear that again. >> You're becoming New York
Mayor.
>> I want to start off with do you agree when your guest
says that the Millers always lied because that's what your guest
on your show just said. >> Chank Chank, do you agree? Do
you agree with every opinion stated on your show? Uh probably
not. the it tends to get people who disagree to come argue on
his show. Obviously, he's probably going to agree with one of
the sides and not the
>> Is that the Millers always lie. And so now I'll continue
into saying Montami just as you here is a socialist. He is someone
who's going to drive New York to the bottom. I'm excited for
him to win because he'll prove to every other single large city
in our country that what you will see is failure. What you will
see is high crime. What you will see is murders. What you will
see is a is a prominent city in our country fall into complete
disrespair disrepair. and you will see large amounts of capital
and tax dollars exit the city immediately because what people
are voting for is their own downfall. When you play into identity
politics as he's done, when you stand behind a podium and your
first comment is, "Oh my gosh, my my aunt on the train instead
of talking about all those who lost their lives on 9/11," then
you're doing something wrong, Pierce. But I will sit here and
say that for for the reasons in which he is wrong and which he
will drive New York into failure is again the same reason why
people on your show instead of arguing the merits as you say
of his opinions they are going to sit here and use attacks on
my husband and myself instead of debating us on our values and
our opinions. It is gross. It is racist and it is bigoted and
I will not join your show again if you >> suck. That's
what I'm debating. >> This is so ridiculous. Yeah. Well,
well, Casey, let me just
No, no, no. Chank, chank, stay out of this. Katy, let me just
respond to that. Casey, normally when someone makes an adoman
attack on another panelist, that panelist who's on the receiving
end gives it back, right? And you've chosen instead, it seems
to me, to to want me to do that for you. I don't mind doing that,
right? But I to me, you could easily respond. You're perfectly
skilled and capable enough to respond to what Shank said about
you, and you've done that. And you've argued, you know, very
passionately why Mandani would be a New York mayor. I'm not taking
sides here. I actually don't like any of the ad hominemum attacks
that come on the show. But it's interesting to note that there
have been an increasing number of very ad hominemum attacks on
Mandani and a lot of it has had a whiff of genuine Islamophobia.
And I don't think it means that any of us have to endorse that
or anything to to actually accept that that is what's been happening.
And I see the same thing happen with candidates in American politics.
I see a stench of anti-semitism from certain quarters towards
candidates. But we certainly see this with Mandali. And it's
ugly and it's horrible and it shouldn't be. >> Yeah, you
are a guest on my show and I appreciate you coming on the show
and I like you coming on the show. [laughter] I think you're
>> are welcome to participate in the anti-semitic attacks
that is so permeating on CNN so I'm sorry I'm sorry I have to
jump in here. Somebody criticizing you personally is not an anti-semitic
attack. If somebody says that you are lying that is not an attack
on that is an attack on you and just >> she did it. She
tried it. She tried it. She literally tried it. She tried it.
She tried it. Sorry, I'm responding. Uh, it looks like the food
shops person responded with a totally Hold on. Let me see here.
Let me refresh.
Sorry, I'm doing I'm trying to do two things at once. If your
framing of things Oh, it's your framing of things when it comes
to association, not mine. Lol.
I think jock doxing you is justified, but because you are engaged
in an unhinged cancellation campaign against Steven for your
beautiful content model. Uh, this is not the point at all. So,
I'll just ask it again. Right? She's running away from a totally
point she made. Like, she actually can't answer that. She can't
apply the standard to me, right? She can't give me an example
of my behavior.
You know what I'm saying? What was your original point? That
if people repeat a totally fabricated belief like let's say um
let's say so totally fabricated can't be supported by evidence.
So, let's say something like uh you know a belief in Scientology.
I was I was using the as the example theans thetens this thing
that like adds negative toxicity to your life in sciento in scientology
in terms of what they believe right if you believe in that it's
usually indicative of you being a scientologist so if you believe
that my community's community ch's community are like doxing
communities you probably are from somewhere where that was presented
to you with no evidence you believe it in a cult-like or or in
in a religious way and so you're probably from DGG if you're
going to go around saying these are doxing communities you're
probably from DG. Do I know that for sure? No. But if you're
stating something totally made up that everybody who is accused
of that is saying is not true and asking for evidence and you
continue to restate it instead of actually engaging, you probably
are like a DGER. Odds are,
So food shops is Well, no. They're just they're they're like
totally evading, right? They're just totally evading the question
here. One second. I'm rolling this back just a second. >> To
win because he'll prove to every other single large city in our
country that what you will see is failure. What you will see
is high crime. What you will see is murders. What you will see
is a is a prominent city in our country fall into complete disrespair
disrepair. And you will see large amounts of capital and tax
dollars exit the city immediately because what people are voting
for is their own downfall. When you play into identity politics
as he's done when you stand behind a podium and your first comment
is, "Oh my gosh, my my aunt on the train instead of talking about
all those who lost their lives on 911," then you're doing something
wrong, Piers. But I will sit here and say that for the reasons
in which he is wrong and which he will drive New York into failure
is again the same reason why people on your show instead of arguing
the merits as you say of his opinions they're going to sit here
and use attacks on my husband and myself instead of debating
us on our values and our opinions. It is gross. It is racist
and it is bigoted and I will not join your show again if you
suck. That's what I'm >> This is so ridiculous. Yeah. >> Well,
let me just
No. No, no, check. Stay out of this. Katy, let me just respond
to that. Katy, normally when someone makes an ad hom attack on
another panelist, that panelist is on the receiving end, gives
it back, right? And you've chosen instead, it seems to me, to
to want me to do that for you. I don't mind doing that, right?
But I to me, you could easily respond. You're perfectly skilled
and capable enough to respond to what Shen said about you, and
you've done that. And you've argued, you know, very passionately
why Mandani would be a New York may. I'm not taking sides here.
I actually don't like any of the ad hominemum attacks that come
on the show. But it's interesting to note that there have been
an increasing number of very ad hominemum attacks on Mandani
and a lot of it has had a whiff of genuine Islamophobia and I
don't think it means that any of us have to endorse that or anything
to to actually accept that that is what's been happening and
I see the same thing happen with candidates in American politics.
I see a stench of anti-semitism from certain quarters towards
candidates, but we certainly see this with Mandarin and it's
ugly and it's horrible and it shouldn't be. >> Yeah, you
are a guest on my show and I appreciate you coming on the show
and I like you coming on the show. [laughter] I think you're
able to are welcome to participate in the anti-semitic attacks
that is so permeating on CNN
ridiculously.
I'm sorry I have to jump in here. Somebody criticizing you personally
is not an anti-semitic attack. If somebody says that you are
lying, that is not an attack on that is an attack on you and
just stop hiding behind identity. This is all the snowflake behavior
that the right is supposedly criticizing the left for that you're
simply >> sorry I'm uh I'm literally having to think through
like typing. It's uh it's pretty rough right now. Okay, I'm very
tired. I'm trying not to type with errors and ask about your
stats on doxing. You're saying you can apply my standard to tie
me to Kiwi farms. I'm saying that is not true. You can demonstrate
how that how Oh, you can demonst Oh my god. I'm like so bad at
typing right now. Hold on. Let me fix this again.
It's rough. It's rough out here. Okay. You can You're saying
you can apply my standard to tie me to Kiwi Farms. I'm saying
that is not true. You can demonstrate how that how applying my
st my own standard to me ties me to Kiwi Farms. Or
you can
you can admit you're wrong. Or you can run. These are the options.
I think these are the options. Okay. I'm I'm EP. Okay, that's
not This doesn't count. This is not This is not indicative of
anything. I'm just big time sleepy. Okay.
Uh I think that's it. I think I'm not fixing it again. Okay.
I'm not fixing it again. Oh, okay. All right. Here's
>> so this is uh me talking about how basically if you
have you know if you have these adjacent if you have these
>> um that me actually I don't even know if you believe
that queen and chud me that our community is dox broadly known
for doxing people have broadly doxed people allow doxing of people
if you have any beliefs like that right then you should be able
to point them out or sorry you should be able to post evidence
for them there's essentially No evidence, no solid link whatsoever.
There's like a clip of there's a chatter and chud's two >> Listen,
these two >> that are like known
>> and I don't think that proves anything because Quimman
did everything he could to fix it after it happened. It was a
total accident and Chud did everything he could to fix it afterwards,
but or his mods did. I don't even think he had to actually do
something. And that that's used as like proof that these are
doxing communities. So if you have a totally delusional belief
that cannot be sourced in any way from reality and the propagator
of that belief is a specific group, right? So you believe in
fatans like the science the Yeah. So in order to tie me to Kiwi
Farms with this standard, you'd have to show that I'm willing
to repeat some thing that's made up whole cloth from Kiwi Farms
with no evidence. Right?
Scientology thing that causes toxicity in your life. Thans, right?
If you believe in Thatans or or your chat believes in Thatton
and you don't say anything about it, by the way, I'm saying if
you have made up beliefs, Missy Elliot, so I'm not even saying
if you believe something. I think you could believe something
that Destiny believes, right? If he can justify it, if he can
actually explain it and show evidence, but there has been no
evidence shown for the claims he's made. So if you are willing
to take his word and only his word despite the other parties
who are accused of this, saying, "No, this is not true. No, we
don't believe in this. No, this is not what our communities are.
Right? And those other parties saying, "Go ahead and show me
evidence. Go ahead and show me any evidence at
Right? If you're if you're going to keep stating that belief,
then I'm going to assume I'm going to assume anybody who's doing
that is from the community
that has faith in Destiny. They will just say, "Okay, Destiny
said it, so I believe it."
They're DGers.
They say she says that I can use or she used that same standard
to tie me I guess to Kiwi Farms and doxing and life ruination
tactics.
So I I don't understand. I I think they just don't comprehend
what's being said in the clip. You just let that that belief
propagate. Then I think your chat are mostly from the cult that
made that thing up. And so that's why when I see the topic come
up and everybody in the chat is repeating the same lie, I'm like,
"Oh, they're a part of the same cult." That that would be my
argument. I think that's pretty easy. And by the way, I would
say for to prove like somebody is a doc, to prove a community
doc is, you'd probably need significantly more of that happening
with less moderation than other communities. And I'd say by any
Oh, yeah. And then if you want to call them like a doxing community,
they'd have to dox significantly more cuz obviously, right, they're
going to be like lone actors who just like freak out and decide
to dox somebody in a community or something. But like you need
a lot of
you need a lot of that happening in an unmodderated fashion to
call it a doxing community. have to happen more than it happens
in other communities. Measure
Chud's community, my community, Queen's community probably beats
DGO by like a mile, right?
Like I again I'd never say like no doxing happens, but it's against
the rules. Those people are banned when the rules are violated.
And like I think uh I think I've unbanned like one or two people
who have done some form of this um after like an appropriate
period of time. and when I don't think it's like um likely to
happen again. Like we had people who were literally in relationships
who might have posted some information about each other at the
end of like a messy breakup kind of thing and I'm like well listen
after 6 months or a year or something like maybe I can unban
but that's like a totally different thing right it's like a oh
you're like
there has to be like significant apologia going on too not apologia
they have to be like significantly apologetic about it. Yeah,
this is this is the core this is the core thing, Miss Elliot.
Yeah.
No substance. It's my my fault. I speak in like a totally rambling
way sometimes.
Uh like that. That's my fault. That's not your fault. Uh what
I should do is I should write the points out when I think of
stuff like this and then condense it so I can say it in a way
that is more succinct.
Right? That's what I should do. Or I should just focus on doing
that I guess in terms of my normal speaking most of the time.
Oh, so buck society. Thank you for the 10 months. Appreciate
it. Was listening to Chud this morning. Never do that. And the
guy tells a story about how his friend slowly drowning a hamster
while his friend slowly drowned a hamster while laughing uncontrollably.
>> Okay, that's
[laughter] that's a little crazy.
All right, I'm going to we're going to restart this. >> In
American politics, I see this a stench of anti-semitism from
certain quarters towards candidates. But we certainly see this
with Mandarin and it's ugly and it's horrible and it shouldn't
be. >> Yeah, you are a guest on my show and I appreciate
you coming on the show and I like you coming on the show. I think
>> are welcome to participate in these anti-semitic attacks
that is so permeating on CNN so ridiculously
I'm sorry I have to jump in here. Somebody criticizing you personally
is not an anti-semitic attack. If somebody says that you are
lying that is not an attack on that is an attack on you and just
stop hiding behind identity. This is all. >> Oh, apparently
food shops is saying I didn't understand what they were saying.
Hold on. They just said to my quote tweet, I don't understand
what they're saying. If I applied the same standard to JTO that
JTO applies to Hutch, that I can easily associate all of the
Destiny antivi farms and doxing and life ruination tactics. Therefore,
using his framework, I can justify defensive doxing doxing. How
how can you tie how can you tie any of this stuff? Or or maybe
hold on. Maybe I misunderstand and maybe she's saying, "Oh, Jay-
Sock's not a Destiny anti fan." In which case, thank you. I think
she doesn't understand what she's saying. And I'm just pointing
that out to people. Why should I care about demonstrating anything
to you? I've seen you justify your relationship with Cherry is
it's just love, bro. I you you literally just said something.
I assume if you want to do this stuff, you want to post on Twitter.
You want to not just say that can't be like actually logically
defended in any way. I'd rather commentate on you from the comfort
of my own stream where I'm actually able to articulate your dishonesty.
You can more easily articulate my dishonesty
streaming than you can in a written reply. I don't I don't like
I I I
literally like I'm sitting here. I'm like, "Hey, you could literally
explain to me what you mean.
Just just explain to me what you mean." I don't, bro. It's like
so embarrassing. How do you watch this person and not feel embarrassed?
Again, I just want to know how she uses my standard, which is
making things up that you have like a cult leader type of person,
right? So, an example of this would be this. I'll I'll lay it
out, okay? Just in case she watches this. All you'd have to do
is find something I said that was totally false, that other people
claimed was was false, and that I refused to back down on that
was sourced from Kiwi Farms,
right? And then I think you would have that if I believe something
that was from Kiwi Farms and I refuse to give it up because other
people were saying, "Give me evidence of that." And I said, "I
don't have evidence. I just believe it." Then you could say then
you could use this standard to say that guy's from Kiwi Farms.
That's how you would do it. That's that's how this should work.
It's so it should be so easy. By the way, that's your claim.
Just so you know, I I maybe maybe this is a little too difficult
for you. That's literally your claim is that I take things or
it's Desty's claim for for sure that I take things from Kiwi
Farms with no facts, no attribution, no nothing, and I just will
not let go of them. I don't think that's true. And I'm more than
happy to prove out anything you ask me to. I I can literally
explain to her how to make her argument, the argument she's trying
to make. I don't think she understands the argument she's trying
to make. Bring her on stream. I mean, I am literally, like I
said, on on like 2 3 hours of sleep. I'm totally mentally
and I think I think I could still easily like dogw walk this
person. I don't know. That might be the uh the the
sleep. That might be the lack of sleep.
What do you say when you haven't gotten enough sleep? You are
not just tired. There's like a word for it. Sleep deprived. Yeah,
that's the one. Sleep deprived. I can't even I can't even figure
out words right now. Okay. I don't know why anybody's watching
this stream to be honest. I can't figure out words. I'm just
kidding. It's an entertaining stream. Okay. It's It's an entertaining
stream even if I can't sleep. All right. Play.
I'm just I'm sitting here like, dude, I I don't know. I
I just feel like it's, you know, you should walk it down with
people once. Like I'm I'm literally sitting here like, "Hey,
we walk it down. We don't even have to have a debate, right?
We're not having a debate here. They're just running away.
I'm literally like, "Hey, here's like all of the stuff. I'm not
I'm just saying if you want to say what your opinion is, you
want to explain how this works. But these people always just
run. They just run instead of actually having a conversation.
She say she can't drive a conversation. Jesus, you're arguing
with a mentally disabled cult victim. Uh yeah, but unfortunately,
okay, unfortunately, the mentally disabled cult victim is like
the what do you call it? Like the totem of Destiny's like Chad
and and community, right?
is like the the representative like Destiny's top representative
right now. It's like food shops, Aerodite, Counterpoints, Empath
Chan. Darius used to be there. Darius has been thrown down. He's
been cast aside, right? It's like Empath Chan, Counterpoints,
Food Shops. Not soite. Those are like the four main pillars now.
But I I'm sure like literally
here's I'm I'm going to just be honest with you. Feel free to
take like an hour or two, maybe eight,
go to your Discord, ask them for help, and then lay the idea
of this out. I'm okay with you crowdsourcing this,
right? Totally. Just crowdsource this. I'm just asking you to
find any evidence. Go to your Discord, get Yogi and your entire
brain trust together and crowdsource this and come up with the
best version of it you can, and let's talk. Like, just post it.
I'm not I'm not here so I can like debate tactic you like literally
just post how you can apply this standard to me right to tie
me and and say any of these are okay or sorry any of what where's
the where's your actual post yeah how any of the life ruination
defensive doxing doxing based on ruining some screw yeah
defend this oh during the 3 days you spent off every stream was
titled Jtock still hiding and now meh I don't even want to explain
to you in a reply Hi. Oh, I didn't even know that. Did was that
the title of their streams? You guys know like we just went on
a vacation, right? Like
unfortunately I I can't say anything like until after the fact,
but that's what happened. Like it was planned multiple days in
advance. Multiple people knew about it. Unfortunately, you guys
live in a world where I can't talk about like that until after
it's happened, right? Like you guys, it would be nice if you
guys could get like a heads up, but I kind of
kind of can't do it, you know? Anyway,
I'm sure they'll keep replying. >> All the snowflake behavior
that the right is supposedly criticizing the left for that you're
simply repeating here. Yes, Steven Miller is a destructive force
in American society. That is not an attack on that has no reference
to his identity. This is an attack on him individually and just
deal with me and all the stuff that he said, >> bro. Uh
I'm not crazy. The audio is like totally on this, right? If I
hit play on this background music, I'm pretty sure if I hit play
on the background music right now. Oh no, never mind. It's my
headphones again. God damn it.
Oh boy, that's their content for the night. I mean, I'm sure
they can explain how I'm being dishonest or something. I'm literally
sitting here like, "Hey, you can come and criticize my positions.
You can criticize how I've covered the
I It's totally fine. Oh, no. I'm not that sleepy. My uh my headphones
are actually just clicking again for some
No, the No, these aren't AirPods. These are these are nice overthe-ear
headphones. They just Windows has
audio cables, the Bluetooth stuff, it just clicks in and out
and sometimes um
as soon as I reconnect them. Oh, it went out when I was talking.
Yeah, when I reconnect the Bluetooth headphones, the microphone
goes out. So,
I just talk through it sometimes. But these headphones are nice.
It's not the AirPods. They're not dying. It's the It's Bluetooth
headphones. If they if the connection gets diminished in Windows
for whatever reason, it starts like clicking. It starts this
stupid [__] clicking that happens and I've I've seen
it. It happens like with a ton of people on Windows. Yeah, it's
it's the it is the Windows Bluetooth stack. Um like every I everybody
I know has this issue, but I'm I'm never going to not use Bluetooth
cuz it's just so nice not having the cord and not having to like
sit at your desk. Oh, dude. Uh hold on. Uh bro, you didn't even
Oh, this is We read this, but then somebody says, "You should
be willing to hop in a call and debate him if you feel that way."
Hell no. I don't want a streamer collaboration. and I want his
career to die. Good way to harm someone's career is to make them
look like an idiot in a debate. You surely seem confident in
your position behind blocks of text. I'm literally telling them
to keep the blocks of text. Uh if you believe something totally
made up that's originated in a cult-like place, you are
a part of that cult. Can be used to justify
doxing. Justify doxing
uh me.
who you think is a Destiny anti-fan. Right? So, I'm actually
inviting you to keep the blocks of text and just comment. I'm
asking you to explain how my standard of
of if you believe something can be used to justify doxing me
who you think is an a Destiny anti, please take your time to
Like, just the I I don't even have like a high bar here. And
again, I'm I'm being really honest about how you prove this.
You just showed that I repeated something from KF,
right? You just showed that I repeated something from KF that
can't be sourced. And then when confronted on it, I refuse to
give that belief up. Right? When somebody says, "Hey, there's
no evidence of this." I go, "Oh, you I No, it's obviously true."
Right? Hold on a second. Can somebody get me their last couple
live stream titles, Riyle, or something? Just their last couple
like live stream thumbnails or titles.
Hold on. They Let me see. Let me find this real quick. Uh,
hold on. Let's see. Oh boy. Okay. Uh, so then it would be like
sometimes replies don't work in uh Twitter. I don't know
Uh, I need to refresh and redo it, don't I? Pete literally went
made a public, right, made a public post about how my standard
could be applied. And then I asked her to explain and she just
ran away.
I would personally feel embarrassed of doing that, right? To
just immediately get totally blown the out. Very interesting.
Yeah, but that would only be able to go after those people. Destin
Suggs,
I was saying the audience overlap meant like calling him a Destiny
Orbiter would probably not be that crazy, right? But again, I
don't even know. I feel like when my audience says things that
I think are totally untrue, totally made up, I feel like I just
go, "No, that's wrong."
So like I I like literally point it out, right? I just more I'm
finding it really funny that this person like can't um defend
their ideas. I'm like exhausted. They're like explicitly running
away.
That's very funny. Here, I'll do this one that they all ran away
from earlier, too. Like I'll literally I could cover it if there's
new What transcript? This is the transcript from
what is it? This is the transcript from the preliminary injunction
hearing,
And I I keep just asking people, I'm like, "Hey, if there's like
new facts in that hearing, right? If there's new facts relevant
to the case, I'll cover it."
And they can't tell me.
I there isn't a new fact relevant to the case. And then somebody
went on and I Where was it? Somebody went on and said,
uh, you only cover stuff that's bad for Destiny. Or they said,
you only cover stuff that's good for one side. And I'm like,
bro, I covered the outcome of the motion that this hearing was
a part of. That was went against Pixie overwhelmingly. Yeah,
that's what it is, Missy Elliot. They're like, "Oh, Pixie said
like a lot." Um, when Andrew Breler totally tried to humiliate
Pixie, that was awesome. Like, why do I why do I want to do that
on stream? Why would I? That seems kind of gross. No,
like that seems kind of gross, but here I am openly out on Twitter
just offering to to argue with these people. Anyway, I don't know.
I I keep thinking like, shouldn't this be really easy for these
people? It should be so easy for these people to come out and
and show the evidence for this. I don't know. Okay. Well, I guess
we go back to this. How
>> Let's go there. >> Whatever you want to call him,
that's You have to be clear about the second. The Israeli state,
right? That's that's how we got here in the first place. Let's
rewind. M Danny and we should be clear about what mom Danny said
in relation to policing in New York and
>> We should how we got here was Jillian very very perfectly
pointed out that we should not use politics to get here and immediately
we went to the state of
>> No, I'm sorry. The state of Israel is not identity politics.
That is a foreign government that is engaged in genocide and
war crimes and we're allowed to criticize that without you pulling
identity politics into [music] this. It is utterly unrelated.
And Manny, by the way, he was not asked about 911 and just randomly
decided to drag his aunt into this. He's talking about Islamophobia
specifically in a context in which he is under relentless islamophobic
attacks including by Andrew Cuomo. And in that context, he brought
up the story of his aunt and the fear that she felt living in
New York City. That is a legitimate part of the conversation.
And you pretending and you pretending that this was comments
about him having uh disregard for the real victims of 911 who
actually died on that day is such dishonest smearing against
him. And I'll say and I'll say [laughter] that he has made
me jump in and the IDF is simply pointing out factual that there
is collaboration there. >> I go to New York a lot. I love
New York and there's no doubt to me that what he has said on
the record mi about the NYPD is deeply offensive to a lot of
New Yorkers and there's no getting away from that. You know him
saying that about the NYPD we have to make it clear
your neck it's been laced by the IDF. That is a really insensitive
thing to say when he >> That is a reference to that is
a reference to an actual program where New York City police go
to Israel on the dime of the ADL or or in in collaboration with
programs through the ADL so they can train with the Israeli police
and Israel military. An apartheid repressive state should not
be training American police. And yes, some of those brutal tactics
do come back to the United States and impact Americans. So simply
pointing a factual statement about the fact that there's a pro
problematic program there of collaboration I think is fair. I
think pointing out frankly it seems like a statement that should
not even be in in dispute or question. I don't know what the
controversy is. Statistics in America show consistently that
brown people and black people are stopped by police more frequently.
So saying that there's a racism problem, that's not an indictment
of policing altogether. Just that's simply pointing out that
there are problems that
you're never going to address these problems if you're afraid
to mention >> Omar Omar Omar Omar he's not saying that
there is some racism. He said, "The NYPD is racist, anti-quer,
and a major threat to public safety. What we need is to #defund
the NYPD." Those are his words in June 2020. Now, he may want
to have a revisionist view of his own words. He may have reigned
back on some of those words, but those words exist in a post
he made on social media. That was his belief. He didn't just
say some of the NYPD were racist or homophobic or a threat to
public safety. He said the NYPD itself in totality was and again
if you live in New York and you rely on the NYPD to police your
streets or if you work in the NYPD that is an incredibly insensitive
and inflammatory thing to
Let me get straight to the point. Gold is up by around 40% this
year. That's not speculation. That's reality. And some of your
savings aren't diversified into gold. You're missing the boat.
Here's the facts. In >> shut up. >> That's one thing.
No, I think sometimes your views are human. I don't I don't I
don't buy into that. Omar, I Omar Omar, I don't buy into that.
I'm sorry. We went a little too far. A little too far. If you're
not running for office
on social media, that's one thing.
>> No, I think sometimes your views are human. I don't
I don't I don't buy into that. Omar, I Omar. Omar, I don't buy
into that. I'm sorry. It shouldn't make any difference. >> You
don't think that when you're running for office, you get an opportunity
to phrase yourself more eloquently. That doesn't count. >> Hang
on. No, hang on. No, sorry. I think what counts is what you honestly
believe in any given moment. He clearly believed that or he wouldn't
oppose it. The idea that when you run for office, suddenly you
change all your opinions. I don't buy that. I actually like to
judge politicians on what they have previously said when they
were civilians because it's often more enlightening about what
they really think about things. And if I was in the NYPD, I'd
be very concerned about Maani given what he said publicly about
the NYPD. And I don't think that's intellectually dishonest.
I think is assessing what Mandani said in real time as his honestly
held belief about the New York Police Department. So you there
are things that look like I say he's charismatic. He's he's clearly
very popular notably amongst young in New York. I think that's
really interesting. He's likely to be the mayor of New York City,
but he thoroughly deserves proper scrutiny of what his views
have been and I think his views about the NYPD are inflammatory
and you know he's got to address that. Um I just hold fire panel
for a moment. I I want to bring in now a Florida uh congressman
uh Randy Fine. Randy Fine, welcome to Uncensored. Um
what is your view of Ma Donnie? I think you want him deported.
Is that right? I do. Look, I think Mam Dami lied in his naturalization
application. He did not share he was a member of DSA. He did
not share his his affiliation and his love for the five Muslim
terrorists. And I think that was dishonest. And I don't think
he should be a citizen. I think that needs to be investigated
as we need to do for many people who've come in over the last
30 years. One of the most fascinating things about this election
in New York is Mandani is losing overwhelmingly among those who
were born in the United States. His only chance
of becoming mayor is because of those who grew up with values
other than being American. And I think that's something that
should alarm everyone.
But the the way you phrase that, you know, if I can pick you
up on that, >> you know, what do you mean? I mean, these
are you have to be born. >> Is he wearing a Kipia Kippa?
Yes, he is. He is. He is. Randy Fine is fighting. Is Randy Fine
versus Ted Cruz in an infinite battle for goodest [__]
in all of America. Okay. >> In America, to be an American,
is that your position? >> No. But by the way, there's a
reason the framers of our Constitution said that to be president
of the United States, you had to be born here. There is something
about growing up here, going through your childhood, being inculcated
with American values, becoming part of that melting pot that
made America great. When my family came here over a hundred years
ago, they came here because they loved America, not because they
wanted to change it. They wanted to become part of the American
social fabric. But what you see in New York is people who have
come here not to become part of America, but to change America.
And that is there's nothing wrong with America, and there's nothing
that fundamentally needs to be changed. This is the greatest
country in the history. How are they trying to change America?
We have >> the world and we have too many people coming
here who do not >> America change is literally a part of
America. Flexibility is a part of the American system. >> Not
believe that. Starting with Mandami
>> You you said yesterday that Shank Yugo, one of our panelists
today is an invader. What did you mean by that? >> I think
it's a great example. I I actually talked in that post about
Mandami. I talked about Elon Omar. I talked about about the the
gentleman you recognize. are all wealthy foreigners who move
to the United States and then constantly talk about how bad it
is. He made a post saying I should be deported to Israel, that
I have dual loyalty. My family's from America. I was born here.
My parents were born here. Most of my grandparents were born
here. My relatives that came here over a hundred years ago came
because they were desperate to be part of the greatest country
in the history of the world. They did not come and then go on
constantly about how bad it is and about how terrible it is and
about how things need to change. If folks want to come to America,
they should love it. They should share its values and they should
want to add value immediately and far too many people who are
coming do not share those values and I believe it is a threat.
The barbarians are no longer at the gate. They are now inside.
>> Wow. So you're calling. >> Dude, it's so crazy
to be like a Christian Zionist. I assume Randy finds a Christian
Zionist. Um it's crazy to be that where they kip you. Okay. And
then on top of that, call like the Muslim panelists co-panelists
invaders. Barbarians at the gate. >> Threat. The barbarians
are no longer at the gate. They are now inside. >> Wow.
So you're calling Chen Yuger a barbarian. We'll give you
>> Oh, normally you don't see people get like this fat
normally. >> Normally into this Cheng, what is your response
to that? >> Yeah. No, I don't mind because I I agree uh
that there are barbarians inside the gate. And that's Randy Fine.
Randy Fine is a sick terrorist sympathizer. Uh in fact, if he
he wants America to do terrorism on Israel's behalf, he has said
we should nuke Gaza. That's millions of innocent children uh
and and human beings and civilians. But he doesn't care. He only
cares about Israeli lives. By the way, the Israelis have murdered
uh now nearly a dozen Americans in the West Bank. No accountability
from our government. And people like Randy Fle say we should
give we owe Israel. We owe Israel a genocide. We owe Israel $300
billion. We owe them uh no No accountability at all when they
kill American citizens. They had a pervert Israeli government
official that came here in Vegas and tried to rap our children
and we let him go. That's insane. Randy Fine, are you asking
for the sick Israeli government to return the so we could face
justice here? No. Randy Fine represents Israel, [laughter] >> Oh
god, dude. Shank Shanks decided there are like so many things
about Israel that are probably like true and need to be criticized
but have for a long time sort of evaded it
um that have evaded criticism on this these like topics through
like oh you're just being anti-Semitic right now. Israel doesn't
broadly protect No but like Israel has a case or two maybe more
than that I don't actually know but I I know there's a thing
that people won't be extradited from Israel on these like charges.
So it's like you could say it's not a broad problem. That's fine.
Go ahead and say that. But what the dude
like like you can't just call it
>> Not America. Everybody knows that. He also said we should
starve all the Gazins. So he's right. There's a sickness inside
our government. Apac and the Israeli lobby have given to 90%
of Congress. They've given him a half a million dollars and that
was a giant waste cuz he works for Israel already. So Randy,
we're all sick of your terrorist sympathies towards Israel. They
have committed 75 October 7th. Their civilian ratio is 83% worse
than worse than any terrorist organization. They have murdered
journalists more than all other conflicts combined. They murdered
104 people today, including 46 children. They burned them alive.
And we're sick of Israeli terrorism and we're sick of people
like you forcing good Americans. I love this country. I didn't
come here to be occupied.
>> Yeah, he really he can't hit the happy merchant the
way Anna can, Rhox. That's the problem. He can't hit the happy
merchant like she can. All right. There's something about
was it was it the sleepy tweet? There's somebody tweeted uh something
I think it was Sleepy tweeted it. Okay. It was
like, "Oh god, thank god Anakasparian had that nose job." All
right. This could have actually ended her career if she hadn't
had the nose job before she did territory of Israel. I came here
because I love America and the freedom and the equality and the
justice that comes with it. If you think your grandparents who
came here were not loyal to America, you know that's your business.
But no, most of the people that come here come because we absolutely
love this country and not Israel. I go serve. Why don't you go
to the Knesset, brother? I Everybody knows you love Israel and
you despise Palestinians and you love Israeli terrorists. So
why don't you move to Tel Aviv already?
>> All right. Randy fin.
>> Well, thank you PI and thank you for the surprise debate.
I actually enjoy that. Look, there's a concept in Islam called
tea where you're allowed to lie in >> Bro, if you if you
didn't realize you were coming here on a debate panel, I don't
know. Did you not watch any of the the show occurring in the
past?
What do you mean? That's literally Did he Does he not know what
the show is >> of your political views? And you just got
a great a great crash course. A great crash course. All of those
things were nonsense. But what to the notion that I am more loyal
to Israel than I am the United States is part of it. Israel is
fighting a war of civilization on our behalf. The reason we need
a state of Israel is because of the Muslims that surround it.
And so I stand with Israel because I believe Israel is fighting
the same fight that we have here in the United States. The same
fight that people like Mandami and Chen, wealthy Muslims who
move here in order to change the complex and the nature of our
country are going to do it. And I won't apologize for that. I
am very proud of my views. I'm very proud of my faith. I'm proud
to be the first member of Congress in the history of the United
States to wear a yamaka, which you may be able to see on my head.
And just in case you didn't, how do you know there's a vegan
joke? >> I know that drives them crazy cuz we're not supposed
to do that. But they gave me the nickname the Hebrew hammer for
a reason and I'm not going to be afraid to use it.
>> But Randy Fine, when you said I don't give a Hang on,
hang on. Hang on, Shank. Hang on, Shank. Randy Fine, when you
said, "I don't give a [__] about Gazins,"
were you proud of that
>> Well, I think the context there is Gaza attacked Israel
on October 7th. of the thousands of people who streamed across
the border to kill every man, woman, and child that they could,
many of them, thousands of them were not quote unquote card carrying
members of. And so when you start a war and you are losing the
war, if you do not like what that is doing to you, then you surrender
in that war. Gaza chose to be the enemy. Gaza chose to attack
Western civilization. And no, I didn't care what happened. It
was my view that if they didn't like it, they needed to surrender.
Something by the way they still haven't done because yesterday
the Gazins killed another IDF soldier in a place that even under
the peace deal they are allowed
I don't
German Randy fine you I've not I've not had actually any guest
I have to be honest here I've not had any guest who has used
the phrase garens rather than given it was specifically
that perpetrated the appalling terror attacks on October the
7th. It is that has the governmental power still in Gaza. It's
not the It's not the Gazan people. It's not the civilian population.
Why are you deliberately conflating Gazans in totality with when
numbers maybe 40 50,000 maximum? >> No, no, no, no. He
he he more than just doesn't care about he hates a he just doesn't
care about gins. Okay, that's he treats gazins way differently
than out of two million.
data brokers truck everything you do online >> because
that is a propaganda lie
never say peers >> shut up because because that is a propaganda
lie I'll give you two points number one thousands of the people
who streamed across the border on October 7th were not members
of that has been well established thousands of people came across
the border who were so-called civilians and second polling just
came out today polling just came out today that said if an election
were held in Gaza today
would win overwhelmingly does that Now does that mean every gazin
supports? No, it does not. But to try to differentiate the two
attempts to imply that some small percentage of gazins support
or like that is not what the data suggests and we should not
allow us to be say these two are completely different. Gazins
and they are >> all right. So all right so Randy fine.
So when for example uh the United States along with my country,
the United Kingdom and others waged what many believe to have
been an illegal war against Iraq in 2003 with the catastrophic
consequences of a million deaths, the rise of ISIS and so on.
Is your position then that in that circumstance every single
civilian American is equally culpable to the military that waged
that illegal war and therefore any repercussions against any
Americans on mainland America would be justified because that's
what you're >> No, no, it's it's not what I'm saying. But
I would note in the war that Israel has fought against Gaza,
the percentage of civilians who have died versus the percentage
of combatants is far lower than we saw in that war. Yet the outrage
perpetrated against Israel in a war where almost a thousand IDF
soldiers have died in order to minimize the casualties in Gaza.
If Israel had wanted to wipe Gaza off the map, it could have
done that. But it didn't because it wanted to minimize the death
that was over there. The only difference between Gaza and Israel
is Israel has the capability to do what it is accused of and
chooses not to. Gaza does not have the capability to execute
the genocide that it wants to because Israel stops it. That is
the fundamental difference between the two sides.
>> All right, Chang, your final response before we let
Randy Fine go.
>> Yeah. So, as you've seen, he's constantly referring
to the Muslims that surround Israel. They're the real problem.
It's open bigotry. He's not even hiding it. And then he'll go
and hide behind the human shields of good innocent Americans
and say, "Oh, no. If you criticize Israel, you're actually criticizing
Americans," which no one did. Uh it's the the dirtiest trick
in the using the anti-semitism card to protect uh his form of
terrorism that he supports which Americans do not support. Uh
and so he says it's okay to kill the Gazins, which is collective
punishment. He's not only said to nuke them and starve them,
but he just said it right here on this air. He's a deeply sick
man who wants to put a moral stain on this country by forcing
us to fund the genocide of the Palestinians. They have already
done 75 October 7th, but it's never enough murder for Randy Fine.
They've already the stadium full. Imagine 20,000 murdered children
lit on fire. Their heads exp. >> This is like accurate.
[laughter] Water buffalo versus porky pig debate. Let's go. >> Israel
did all of that. And Randy Fine is saying it's not enough. Americans
go work another shift cuz you got to send Israel more money to
more Palestinian children and put that on America's soul. Don't
listen to this guy. He doesn't believe in America. He just his
whole point is to make sure that we fund his beloved Israel and
their sick disgusting terrorism. [clears throat] Israel is the
largest terrorist entity.
>> No, nobody said that. You're the only one who says it.
You're the sick, disgusting Muslot.
No one wants anti-semitism. The only person who wants anti-semitism
is you. Cuz you want to hide behind it. You bring up your when
no one else did. No one
people. This guy is absolutely like he's just totally victimizing
himself in his mind over and over again and he's lived in an
environment where for some reason I don't know what the reason
is but for some reason people used to support him in doing that.
They used to always cuddle him when he did that right and now
he's doing it here and Shank isn't coddling him at all and he's
like go ahead call me all call me all these slurs. It's like
nobody's calling you that you're >> Yamaka except you brought
it up as if like you're some sort of victim. You're the one who
wants to know for a million victim at all. You're not a victim.
You're a disgusting terrorist sympathizer and you should not
be the United States Congress. You are on this
You are trying to occupy America. So will you steal our money
to send money over to Israel to steal Palestinian and Arab and
Muslim land. And on on top of that, peers, one thing that's important
is pro-Israel people like Randy Fine have spread hatred and fear
of Muslims in this country my entire life. They have tried to
get everyone to hate Muslims so that they could say, "Oh, look,
uh, now we Israel is defending Western civilization. You should
murder all the Muslims and you should let Israel take all of
their land because we are defending Western civilization." And
then they have the audition. Do you mind if I anti-semitism?
>> Do you mind if I make my closing remark? >> We
are the biggest in the country
literally for a minute.
>> No, you can't. The check momentum started. Okay. He
takes some time to slow down after a while. All right. You cannot
slow him down automat. He can't auto stop. He can't just stop
on a dime. All right. He is like a buffalo. All right. He's charging
and he's going to go through some things before he slows >> Okay.
I just want to make it clear to to viewers before you Randy.
I'll give you one final uh response because to be fair to you,
you did not know you would be engaging in a wider debate with
other panelists. I decided to bring Chen in because you called
him a barbarian invading the United States. I think if you do
about a panel member >> Oh, wait. Piers. Piers did actually
ambush him. Damn. W content.
Dude, Piers Piers is uh Piers knows the game. All right. This
facelift not working for him, but his brain in general, he knows
content. He knows how to he knows how to make the content happen.
Okay. I just noticed this. He's like He looks weird as Okay,
he looks weird as I feel like he just got a >> They're
entitled to respond. >> He's now obviously responded angrily
and passionately to you. I'll give you one last word back and
then we're going to move. I would note I did not do that on the
show. You could have warned me in advance, but again, I don't
mind I don't mind having the debate. I would note this. If Islamophobia
was the big issue that Senk makes it out to be, Mami would not
have had to lie and make up an aunt that did not exist who was
not in the United States dealing with so-called Islamophobia
after 9/11. If the problem was real, the stories would be endemic
and they would be everywhere. So, people need to not believe.
What do >> you mean the story? What does the stories would
be endemic? What the does that mean? He just knows mom Donnie
said endemic. That's like Darius using um oh what it paraphernalia.
It's like the same thing just happened, right? You hear a word
and then you just use it even though you have no idea what it
>> The nonsense. The fact of the matter is if you hear
someone yell Allahu Akbar walking down the street, you're probably
going to take cover. Fear of Islam is rational. Doesn't mean
all Muslims are. >> That's not true at all. You hear them
sound or saying it like screaming it like a deranged maniac.
Maybe if you hear them going Allahbar and doing some bows on
a on a mat, I'm going to assume they're praying,
right? This guy, dude, Chen called you a bigot. You're like,
"Oh, yeah. Anybody blessing God in is uh what would it be?
What would the What do you call the spoken word? Islam." You
don't, right?
Oh, God. I'm losing words so badly. Arabic. Thank you. [__]
me. Holy [__] No, I'm just like I'm I'm having like
a fasia or something tonight. Weird that I can pull that word
out of nowhere, but
Arabic Jesus >> bad. They are not. But this concern that
many Americans have and that they have in your home country,
it is real. And I thank you for having me on your show today.
Happy to come back anytime. >> It's not a carbon monoxide
leak. I've at the best of times in my life, I always have like
a slight case of this and when I'm tired, it just gets exacerbated
like super badly.
>> Okay, Randy, fine. I appreciate you coming on. Thank
you very much. We're going to go back to the panel now who've
been waiting patiently there. Um,
>> I just I got no sleep. I got like three hours for this
debate. This has been raging now for not just two years. This
has been this is a debate that's raged for decades. Um, >> and
just to be clear, I'd still probably talk to food shops.
>> I think even if I can't find words, even if I totally
if words like leave my mind randomly, I feel like that's an appropriate
handicap to make that at least a little interesting, right?
>> Talk big picture about Israel for a moment. There was
a flare up in the last couple of days where it appears that uh
members of although they say it was a splinter group and not
them killed several IDF soldiers. As a result, Netanyahu ordered
a fresh barrage of bombardment uh into Gaza. That has now stopped.
Uh they're not saying it's the end of the ceasefire. We have
the Qatari prime minister was an interesting intervention I think
because they've been obviously pivotal in trying to uh get this
peace process resolved. He said that the deadly attack on Israeli
soldiers in Gaza and the strikes in response by Israel were very
disappointing and frustrating for us. But he added that's basically
a violation by the Palestinian party. Whilst he noted that claimed
it was not communicating with the group who carried out the attack,
which I thought was a measured response to this. Crucially, it
seems the ceasefire in in the big picture is holding. Do you
think it can hold or do you think we're going to see a lot more
of this and the thing is going to blow apart? I >> I speak
only as a layman who wants to see the stop. I This has gone on
from what I can glean for thousands of years. It's very complicated.
I've listened to experts on both sides. I'm hopeful.
My optimism is waning a bit. Um but I think if we if we don't
hope, then what do we have? Right? If if you're not fighting
for peace, what are you fighting for? I I think you've got all
of many of the other Arab nations involved and invested. That's
exceptionally encouraging. you have numerous guarantee guaranurs
of this peace deal, but you know to see already what's going
on. It is discouraging and it is alarming and again I'm not an
expert on this. All I can tell you is I want people to stop dying
and I can acknowledge atrocities committed on both sides and
that's where I stand on it. I want it to stop.
>> Okay, Omar, I mean isn't isn't that as an overview of
here something we should all share and embrace?
I mean, I would dispute the idea that this has been going on
for thousands of years. Uh, this is a way to just say, "Oh, this
is a conflict between Muslims and and whatever, and it goes back."
The truth of the matter is, we are dealing with a very modern
problem. The modern state of Israel is ruling over all of Palestine,
imposing a system of apartheid, denying Palestinians their basic
rights. They're putting them under a military occupation where
they don't have the right to movement, don't have the right to
attend court, don't have the right to vote for the government
that rules their lives, and can't move out without Israeli permission.
It's a system of domination of one people over another. And that
is the core problem and that is precisely why we are in the situation
that we're in. Now, of course, atrocities do exist on both sides.
There's no denying it. But we have to be clear about the fact
that it is only when there is Palestinian violence towards Israel
do we talk about this as a controversy, as a breaking of a ceasefire.
You know, we have to note about the fact that since the beginning
of the ceasefire, before this attack, Israel had killed more
than 100 Palestinians in Gaza. And yet, you did not hear anybody
talking about that as a violation of the ceasefire. That includes
a bus full of children who are looking for shelter with their
parents driving around looking for some place to be. And those
children get killed and nobody bats an eye. But the second that
there is an unknown attack on an Israeli soldier, then we talk
about this as a violation of the ceasefire and Israel is going
to explode and retaliate by murdering another 100 people, half
of them children. I mean, we just have a completely lopsided
way of looking at this where Palestinian life is considered dispensable.
It doesn't count for anything. Israel can murder them left and
right, but only when there's violence towards, in this case,
Israeli soldiers who are occupying forces in Gaza, that somehow
becomes a point of tension and attention. We start talking about
which party is responsible for a ceasefire violation. It's entirely
silly and it misses the point underneath. Just last point. Last
point, peers. There is no ceasefire. What there is is pressure
from the United States administration on Israel to scale back
the genocide. So that instead of 100 people a day, now they're
killing 100 people every couple of weeks. That's the rate at
which we're going. But there's still a dynamic in which there's
an effort to get rid of Palestinians and there's no prospect
for Palestinians to be a free people who rule themselves in Palestine.
And that means that this problem is going to
>> Okay. Casey Miller, I think it's now been confirmed
that one IDF soldier died. I think initially reported it was
two, but either way, when you have the Qatari prime minister
who's they've been acting as mediators with this, when you have
them confirming it was basically a violation by the Palestinian
party,
then they're acknowledging even in the Arab world that this latest
flare up was precipitated by the death of an IDF soldier. Now,
people can argue about the scale of the response from Israel,
but thankfully it has already stopped. Well, check you can check
your head, but I mean the reality is they responded to the death
of one of their soldiers. We may not like the scale of it, but
that's what they responded to in this in this particular flare
up. The more important thing for me, Katy Miller, by both sides
of the moment, >> third party is not a response to this.
>> Well, you like I say, you may not like the scale of
response. >> They murdered children because one of their
SS soldiers was killed and it wasn't even by Are you kidding
me? So, they're occupying 53% of Gaza. >> I don't know.
[__] I've not been following I've not been following
the stuff going on in Gaza recently, so I I don't know the particulars
here. So, shouldn't they get the hell out of Gaza? So, one of
their soldiers gets killed and we're supposed to shed a tear
for the occupiers. In reality, they murdered 46 children. They
murdered 46 children today. I can't stand the terrorism of
>> Yeah. But you know what, Chank? When you call when you
call the IDF SS soldiers and you compare them directly to the
Yes. Yes. And you know they're I I'm not >> Listen, Chank,
I know that 46 kids died, but have you thought about how mean
you're being? Have you thought I just want to ask you, Chank,
have you thought about how mean you're being right now? I know
kids died. Okay, I get it. I get it. Listen, kids died, but is
that any call for a comparison to the Because these people are
murdering kids indiscriminately? Is that really >> I find
that horrible.
>> So, no, no, no. Israel does. Hold on. Uh, let me explain.
So, Israel does not get a pass on committing another genocide
because people suffered the Holocaust. What happened?
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
[laughter]
All the pograms were disgusting. That doesn't mean that Israel,
>> you caught that, right? She's suggesting that Steven
Miller is going to review Chank's like immigration application,
right? Like this is psychotic. This should be the kind of thing
that makes it like you basically have a choice. Your wife either
never goes and makes a public appearance. Like if this is 10
years ago, your wife never makes a public appearance again on
anything like this or you're fired. This might have just gotten
you fired automatically if you're in Steven Miller's position.
in the Trump administration. Uh Trump's probably just like I
support Katie Miller or some >> pretending to represent
Jews across the world gets to commit another genocide upon a
totally innocent people and collective punishment and children
over and over again AND GO I GET TO DO IT. I GET TO DO A GENOCIDE.
I DON'T do a genocide. THERE IS NO FREE. >> YOU KNOW WHAT
I get to do? What I get to All right, Jen. What I get to do is
invite every member of the panel to speak fairly and openly.
And my question was directed to Katie. I mean Katie look you
know from my point of view
>> and they are they're committing let% of the kids say
sniper shots to the head or chest they're literal terrorist >> let
Katie Miller speak check let Katie speak Katie
>> I will just say this pers this is my last time on this
program if you're going to invite open anti-semitics to participate
on your platform and not call it out for what it is [laughter]
which is
>> hit her hit her with the Larry Ellison right now Jank
hit her you have to hit her with the Larry Ellison it's critical
You apply the Larry Ellison right now. >> Pulled it out.
>> I JUST PULLED IT OUT. >> They're inviting him
back, giving him the air. >> What more do you want me to
do? >> His hatred toward people like myself,
>> deplatform this anti-semite
family and again not debate the merits of the argument.
What kind of lunatical are you? >> In the last segment
with Rep. Randy Fine, what you said was he had said the word
Muslim. He never once said the word Muslim. You immediately turn
it to identity politics, which are more than identity politics.
>> He did. He did say the word Muslim. He did say Muslim.
He did. I heard him. He did say it.
>> What you're doing by comparing the SS and the IDF is
once again saying that the Israeli state, you're coding it for
just saying. You're saying that October 7th and what happened?
Let's not forget [laughter] that came from Gaza near daily into
Israel. >> Jake, let's finish. Let's not forget. Let's
not forget who held Israeli hostages. Was that all? No, that
was also Gazin civilians. Why can't they find and return all
of the bodies of the hostages? Why? We saw on video yesterday
from an IDF drone that a body was recovered and >> Israel
was genociding Gaza and you can't keep track of what's going
on in Gaza when it's under relentless bombardment from the north
to the south. I mean, it's it's incredible. We're looking at
a literally Israeli soldiers are shooting children in the head,
snipers. Were they all Hamas or were >> I would like to
ask Katie Katie, let me ask you a question. The thing I found
offensive of of what Brandy Fine said amongst other things actually,
but his particular statement uh in which he repeatedly referred
to Garins's not I don't think that helps anybody in this
We know what they are. They're an armed military and political
power in Gaza. They do not represent every Gazin. And to try
and constantly call the people October the 7 Gins, I think it's
wrong. Okay, good. because I think it's wrong. In the same way,
I find it offensive when Jake says when Jake says, "Yeah, but
Jake says the idea for the SS." I find that incredibly offensive
particularly given that they're Jewish.
Why is that offensive?
>> Because you're singling you're comparing them
to the people that waged the
By the way, you could also call them Turks. You could also call
them Ottomans. You could call them Serbs. You could call them
members of Pope's campaign. You can call them anything you like.
They're all genocides. Now, the Holocaust was even worse. I I
get that. But at the same time, it is a genocide. And frankly,
when you just simply look at what is left of Gaza, have you seen
the footage of it? There's nothing left there. The overwhel There's
complete and total destruction.
And it's admitted to by Israeli leaders themselves. They're saying
that they're trying to make Gaza unlivable for Palestinians.
They're telling you it's a >> I don't disagree, Omar. I
don't disagree. And when I hear people like Smodri and Ben, I
think they talk in genocidal language. I've classified it myself
as ethnic cleansing. They've made no secret that they want to
kick all the Palestinians out of Gaza. I think it's disgusting
and reprehensible. And when the Israeli government officials
we've had on try and pretend that their views don't matter and
we should ignore Modric and Bengu, I say why? Why should be the
senior members of the government for God's sake? So I have, as
you know, both of you, you and Shake both know, I've expressed
increasingly critical views about the Israeli government strategy
in Gaza all this year. But I prefer not to get into, you know,
debates about this stuff where you shout over Katie Miller and
start calling the IDF, the SS. I think it's just unnecessary.
Now, going back to Katie Miller. Katie, do you think we're going
to get a lasting >> Poor little genocide. >> All right.
Is Is your name Katie Miller? Chang. No, it's not. You're not
Katie Miller. Katie Miller, do you think we're going to get a
lasting peace here or
>> I think we will because again, this is a this is a centuries
long war as Jillian has said that has persisted for many, many
years. For once we have United
For once we have a president who stands
again this is a this is a centuries long war as Jillian has said
that has persisted for many many years and force
>> wait what
they're not talking about Israel Palestine are they like that
that there's no way I'm I miss what they're referring to >> Miller
Jen no you're not you're not Katy Miller Katy Miller do you think
we're going to get a lasting piece here or
I think we will because again this is a this is a centuries long
war as Jillian has said that has persisted for many many years.
>> The the lost Judea the Jews lost Judea. They didn't
take Judea back until the UN gifted them part of Judea after
them peacefully migrating there. Right? Like they they lost it.
They were
cast out. They were uh I don't I don't know what are we supposed
to do here? They haven't been there for hundreds of
Yeah, some have been there, but broadly the the base of the Jewish
people have not been there for hundreds of years.
>> And force united, >> it's not biblical either.
>> For once, we have a president who stands up and says,
"Let's be done with this." Who brings everyone together, all
of the countries in the Middle East to uphold a peace agreement.
And whether that is one IDF soldier being killed or two and skirmishes,
whether that is
>> they're going to make me they're going to make me play
the um the Judea Denda est clip from from an unbiased history.
Okay? And nobody wants to do that here. All right? Nobody wants
to make people relive that >> themselves after this peace
after this ceasefire which we saw in the streets of Gaza, right?
Is that all we want to have happen is a lasting peace between
Israel and the Palestinians. That is it.
Yeah, that is utterly clueless. I'm sorry, but does not know
what he's talking about >> because Donald Trump is the
most clueless president about this stuff. Sure, he's throwing
his weight around trying to make sure that there isn't a ceasefire
because he's desperate to get some kind of Nobel Peace Prize
for peace or whatever or portraying himself as the peace president,
but he will not do the minimum that is required for a long and
just peace and that is Palestinians to be free. And a president
who doesn't understand that Palestinians being a free people
in their own land is a prerequisite is not going to achieve long-lasting
peace. Would you rather war
>> Would you rather the hostages? >> No, I'd rather
the problem be solved. I'd rather Israel be isolated diplomatically
and militarily and financially until it ends its brutal occupation
over Palestinian territory
to be free. That's how you solve the >> No, you just keep
saying nonsense. >> I do think of all the things of all
the things to attack Donald Trump. >> All right. Of all
the things to attack Donald Trump about, him actively trying
to wage peace and maybe getting a Nobel Peace Prize seems to
me the least the least problematic thing about Donald Trump.
that a Republican American president who actively seeks peace,
not war, should be celebrated by everybody. Right? So I think
when you when this is what I mean about Trump arrangement syndrome
and people can't even give him credit, can't even give him credit
for trying to find peace. >> What's wrong with that? >> You
can't give him credit. Somebody who funds a genocide and then
decides to arbitrarily put a stop to it briefly by putting some
pressure on Israel to cut it out and who basically encourages
Israel to bomb Iran and then 12 12 days later takes credit for
having stopped that war. You can't be the initiator of war and
genocide and then try to take credit for being the peace president
because you put in your own nonsense. That is not how it works.
>> What happened? >> Let's be honest. October 7th
is what started this.
>> All right.
Palestinian were being before several hundred were killed in
20 before October 7th. >> All right. We we are moving on.
We are going to move on. >> That went on for hundreds of
years. Why did October 7th start it now?
I She was just saying it's hundred years old. Hundreds of years
old. biblical.
Now, October 7th was the start. Okay. >> Briefly to a couple
of other topics I wanted to mention. Katie, while I've got you
talking to me, I wanted to mention this is where you and Jake
Tat Tapper got into it over the former White House press secretary
Karine Jean Pierre. Let's take a look. [snorts] >> She
is quite incompetent to do the job. Right. This is what Republicans
have been saying for years now is that she is just another evidence
that DEI doesn't work. Whether that's in the White House in your
press secretary role or whether that's a you know an air traffic
controller, an air pilot, whether that's your doctor, you know,
you don't you want to hire the best for the role, not not just
based on skin color. Jake, why did she get the job over John
Kirby? >> Well, why are we assuming that she is a black
LGBT, you know, gay woman is DEI, but a white woman who is behind
the podium right now, which DEI initially started as affirmative
action, which was about affirmatively hiring women and minorities.
Why is one DEI and the other is not? >> Why did she get
the job over John Kirby? because as everyone has said this week,
she is woefully incompetent. >> She had the job long before
Junker. >> I will I will just say she used to be a commentator
on CNN, then she was one on MSNBC and she was good at that. Like
I mean I I'm without getting into the job I thought she did as
press secretary. I I thought I it it didn't seem crazy to me
because she was eloquent as a as a >> Why is she trained
every four sentences to say she is a black queer LGBTQ woman?
Because that's how she's been promoted her entire career. >> You
know, that's what's interesting to She's so proud of herself.
Holy.
>> Her entire career. >> That's like the most insane
smug face.
dude. What?
That's That is That is incredibly offensive. Holy sh Holy. She's
so proud of herself.
My god.
You know, I thought it was interesting debate, Katie. I mean,
on her book tour, all we've heard from Jean uh Queen Jeep Pierre
is her repeatedly saying how proud she was to be a black queer
LGBTQ woman. Let's take a look.
>> As a black woman, as a person who's also LGBTQ,
as a black woman, as a black woman, I am a black woman. I am
a queer woman. I'm an immigrant. Being a black woman, as a black
woman myself, that is the thing that I understood as a black
woman that I meant a lot to people of because of the communities
that I represented and whether it was women of color, black women,
queer community, LGBTQ community, immigrant, and as a black woman
and I have my querness, too. >> I mean, as an advertisement
for DEI gone wrong, there you have it in her own
>> Wait, hold on. What? I don't even know what she did
wrong. I I don't know what she what did she do wrong that she
was DEI. I think it's it's like super weird to to just like signal
with those things, but I she would have to be bad at the job.
Where's the evidence she was bad at the job of press secretary?
>> I think if Donald Trump's taught us anything, it is
you can have the least useful human beings on planet Earth be
the press secretary for the White House.
she could do to justify her performance in which to remind everybody
for two years she kept telling us how brilliantly cognitively
aware Joe Biden was when it was quite obvious that the complete
opposite was true. So she was lying from that podium and I don't
care about her skin color or but my god she cares about it and
so when people wait
hold on hold on
is lying at that podium a sign of incompetence is being hired
for like certain traits like being the blonde attractive woman
who is hired by the Trump campaign to stand up there and lie
for them. Like which one of these criticisms don't apply equally
to
who the is this Kristen? I can't remember who the press secretary
is right now.
Stupid blonde person. >> Talk about DEI and they look at
the way she's been handling her book tour. All they're hearing
is identity politics that the >> Carolyn Levit I honestly
can tell you like the stuff that I've heard Carolyn Levit say
that me off. Oh, dude. I
uh we'll see. I don't know if we're making it past four hours
today, guys.
I I'm having a struggle right now. We'll see. Maybe I'll try
some more caffeine and and then we'll see how that goes.
>> The reason we should rate her as a press secretary is
because she was a black queer woman. Well, sorry, I don't. I
rate you on whether you are any good in your job.
>> Wait, is that is that the what like the first clip?
Hold on, let me grab this
>> Tapper got in. >> She is quite incompetent to
do the job. Right. This is what Republicans have been saying
for years now is that she is just another evidence that DEI doesn't
work. Whether that's in the White House in your press secretary
role or whether that's a you know an air traffic controller,
an air pilot, whether that's your doctor, you know, you don't
you want to hire the best for the role, not not just based on
skin color. Jake, why did she get the job over John Kirby? >> Well,
why are we assuming that she is a black LGBT, you know, gay woman
is DEI, but a white woman who is behind the podium right now,
which DEI initially started as affirmative action, which was
about affirmatively hiring women and minorities. Why is one DEI
and the other is not? >> Why did she get the job over John
Kirby? because as everyone has said this week, she is woefully
incompetent. >> She had the job long before John Ker. >> I
will I will just say she used to be a commentator on CNN, then
she was one on >> Honestly, at least DEI is somewhat blind,
right? And I say that like jokingly, a little tongue and cheek,
but at least it's like, okay, it's just some categories. The
DEI for the Trump administration is literally hiring will blow
Trump. That's like that's their version of the problem with DEI
is you hire less competent people. The problem with whatever's
going on the Trump administration is they find the least competent
people somehow.
They find
it's so much worse than whatever DEI is. BC and she was good
at that. Like I mean I I'm without getting into the job I thought
she did as press secretary. I I thought I it it didn't seem crazy
to me because she was eloquent as a as a >> Why is she
trained every four sentences to say she is a black queer LGBTQ
woman? Because that's how she's been promoted her entire career.
Okay, that is again
not relevant to how she does as press secretary, right? Does
she say that at the podium? Is that her saying that at the podium
all the time? Surely in Shanks Jesus
in Shanks like little clip here, we're going to see her say that
at the podium, right? I mean, >> as a black woman, as a
person who's >> Nope, this is this is her after writing
a book. >> LGBTQ as a black woman. As a black >> this
is her talking to Megan Kelly. I am a black woman. I am a queer
woman. I >> This is the Megan Kelly show, but I don't think
this is Megan Kelly >> immigrant being a black woman as
a black woman myself. That is the >> Is this all from her
promoting her book tour? Where was she saying she was a black
woman when she was like at the >> The thing that I >> Where
was she using that as like a weapon when she was doing her job
>> to people of >> Yes. This is her doing a press
a press run like for a book tour. Yes. because of the communities
that >> so I kind of see why she's selling it for her book
tour. It's about selling who she is. >> I represented whether
it was women of color, black women, queer community, LGBTQ community,
immigrant, and as a black woman and I have my querness, too.
>> All right, [snorts]
If you read her her New Yorker interview that she did, she gives
an excuse for that the fact that Joe Biden was wrongfully kicked
off the ticket and that's why she left the Democratic party.
It's not because the Democratic party did anything wrong, right?
She perpetrated the biggest fraud in the American people. But
yet, she also says Kamala shouldn't have been the presidential
nominee, but also says Kamala was wronged because because she's
a black woman. She she should have been more celebrated as the
nominee. She has so many hypocrisies in one sentence, but then
every other sentence talks
>> that's not a hypocrisy. Those are totally those don't
conflict. Oh, she shouldn't have been the nominee. She wasn't
effective. But she should have been celebrated more as a black
woman nominee as the first black woman to be nominated for president
to run for
How how is that conflicting at all >> about her black queerness?
And at a certain point, you either stand on the merit that you
are qualified to do the job, which we all know after watching
two years of her every day give this very terrible press conference,
is that she wasn't qualified to do the job. And to me that is
emblematic of the larger problem of the last four years of the
Biden administration in which people were not chosen based on
their merit or their qualifications. They were chosen solely
based on their race and whether you saw that again with pilots
in the sky or your doctor or air traffic controllers which if
you looked at when President Trump came in on January 6 there
was qualifications that said we prefer the hiring of dwarfs.
That is really what it said and that's not what I want in my
air traffic controllers. I want best for the job. >> Okay.
All right. Check Yug when you look
>> I feel like intuitively I want to say that a dwarf would
be worse at that job but I don't know that
what I guess uh oh the the signals would have to be smaller right
cuz the arms would be shorter so the signals wouldn't be as interpretable
right but again if they're just sitting in a oh wait that's that's
people outside like the people signaling the people sitting in
the box
why can't they read a screen saying where the planes are
oh my god you have to pull Pull up now. Pilot, pilot, you have
to pull up now. Is it that they have the goofy Oompa Loompa voice
and then that is going to make the pilot laugh and crash the
>> Karine Jean Pierre's book tour and you see the repeated
identity politics that she's spewing here to justify her role
and her performance. You must cringe too, don't you? I mean,
nobody wants to see somebody who just endlessly says, "I'm so
proud." >> Alpha Tango, you are you're on a crash course.
Come on, man. Be for real. You're on a crash course. You got
TO PULL UP NOW. COME ON, DUDE. Stop joking. Put a put an adult
on the thing. >> Proud of being a black queer woman at
that podium. Why would anyone care that she's a black queer woman
at that podium? Why don't we just >> What did Did she use
So she's just going to run with her doing it at the podium.
Bro, what are we talking about?
>> I I do totally cringe. Uh I hate to say it, but I half
agree with Katie here. Uh, so the the half I don't agree is
>> Chenk is desperately trying to find some common ground.
All right, he's
>> bro. She got the smug face on again. Ah, Chank, not
good. Not good, Chank. I do not approve. This was actually gross.
What the [__]
>> Okay. Um, so I don't agree that she was hired for that
position because she's a black woman or she's queer, etc. She's
perfectly capable of being a liar like every press secretary
for every president is. Their job is to literally lie for the
president. In fact, when Karine Jean Pierre was asked, "Hey,
do you have any sympathy for the Palestinians? Do do you feel
regret any of the propaganda you did, you know, at the time in
that role?" She said, "Well, I'm a queer black woman, so I was
proud of that what I did." What? That doesn't make any sense.
They're asking you about a substantive policy question, and you're
answering, "It's okay. I'm allowed to do whatever I want cuz
I'm a queer black woman." No, you're not. There is no such pass.
Okay? And so so and she's obsessed with identity politics and
I can't stand it. It's a losing strategy. It's a very selfish
strategy. And by the way though, Katie, now we have a different
DEI in the in this administration which is you must show loyalty
to Israel. If you don't show loyalty to Israel, you won't get
hired and you'll not
Okay, but it is let's not get No, no, hang on. Let's not get
back into Israel. No, wait, wait one second, Omar, cuz I just
want to I just want to reference on this similar issue. We had
another black queer person by their own uh self- definitionf,
Don Lemon, who attacked Megan Kelly on her looks in a way that
I found fascinating. Let's take a look at >> Megan Kelly,
my final words, kind of looks like a Barbie doll covered in like
>> I think she looks trans.
>> Let's end on that note. >> She looks, as I say,
she looks >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. These people have to all say, "Okay, okay, that's funny,
right?" There's no way they could be the comedy is back people
and actually virtue signal about this. It's just going to be
performative hypocrisy signaling. Right. You told this way to
respect trans people. Now you're joking about trans people. What
the man? So she said he said there that she looks trans and looks
clockable, which I'm told refers to a term used to describe a
trans person who is not passing as their biological gender. What
what I'm struck by, Jillian, about that >> no talkable
would be that they would be passing as their biological gender
peers >> was uh there's Don Lemon, the great, you know,
standard bearer for the black uh >> although biological
gender
community seemingly using trans as a derogatory way to describe
somebody. I'm >> I [laughter] mean, he's the ultimate hypocrite.
I am not a Don Lemon fan. >> It's just hypocrisy. The reality
IS THAT I PERSONALLY [screaming] am witnessing
this kind of othering and name calling. I mean, you're seeing
this on both sides. You've got a freaking what was it a text
chain that came out on the Republican side with anti-semitic
slurs and racist slurs and then you've got a Democratic candidate
that had a and also had racist slur. Like this is happening
>> on both sides. And instead of pointing fingers and who's
doing it and who did what and who's for it and who isn't, it
should be unilaterally condemned. Identity politics is gross.
Period. It does happen on both sides and it should be isolated
and marginalized. That Wait,
Sorry, not not I'm sure Jillian Michaels is saying something
equally, but what is
How how the [__] is Trump saying this? You just pardoned
this. I don't know who he is, says President Trump, claiming
he doesn't know Changpang Xho, aka CZ, a man he pardoned. CZ
is a billionaire who plead guilty in 2023 to violating anti-moneyaunder
moneyaundering laws. The government said at the time that he
was he allowed terrorist groups to move millions of dollars around
the world. Yes.
But he also he also allowed World Liberty Financial to obtain
what $2 billion in initial funding for their stable coin. Right.
Crypto company. So CZ does not mention here the CEO of Binance,
the largest crypto exchange on the planet. Former CEO of Binance
crypto firm World Liberty Financial.
>> Wait, why did this not have sound? Okay, here we go.
>> So far this year, the president has pardoned or shortened
the sentences of more than 1,600 people. The latest pardon was
for a cryptocurrency
who is known as CZ.
This should be totally unacceptable for the president to be asked
like, "Why did you pardon this guy?" He goes, "I don't even know
who the that is." >> The company CZ founded, Binance, helped
boost the profile of the Trump family's crypto firm, World Liberty
Financial.
He plead guilty in 2023 to violating anti-money laundering laws.
Right. >> The government at the time said that CZ had caused
significant harm to US national security essentially by allowing
terrorist groups like to move millions of dollars around. Why
did you pardon him? >> Okay, [laughter]
>> dude. That's such a killer question. He's just going
to go, that's a stupid question. I don't know who that is. Next
>> Are you ready? I don't know who he is. I know he got
a fourmon sentence or something like that. And I heard it was
a Biden witch hunt in 2025.
>> I'm so I don't know. How do you This is what I'm talking
about. Ezra Klein's over here like we have to be more accepting
of people. We have to figure this out. It's like bro that's not
enough of a paradigm shift. It's like this guy just to say just
gets to say totally insane. I don't know. >> His crypto
exchange Binance helped facilitate a $2 billion purchase of World
Liberty Financials stable coin. And then you pardon CZ.
How do you address the appearance of pay for play? >> Well,
here's the thing. I know nothing about it cuz I'm too busy doing
the other. I can only tell you that. >> No, I can only
tell you this. >> Who signed the pardon? Is it an autopan
>> um my sons are into it. I'm glad they are because it's
probably >> Dude, there's what? Shut up, dude. Uh just
say like I can't comment national security or some [__]
Okay, please for the love of God, stop just
Yeah, guys, it was really bad when uh it was really bad when
there was the appearance of impropriety with Hump Hunter Biden.
Okay, Trump's like, "Yeah, my sons just told me to pardon this
guy and then I did it and then they made millions of dollars.
My my sons are like really into crypto and they wanted this guy
pardoned and so, you know, he gave some money. I You're telling
me just now for the first time?" I just do presidential actions
for my sons. That's all. I just do presidential actions for my
sons. I I use the full power of the presidency to further my
son's business interests. Why not, guys? >> A great industry,
crypto. I think it's good. You know, they're running a business.
They're not in government >> because you were >> world
Liberty Financial has denied any involvement in the pardon.
Sorry, I'm hitting my head into my mic. I don't know if you can
hear it. I'm sure it would be funnier if you could see me. So,
he threw his So, his son's company threw him under the bus, too.
Did they? I don't even know, man. It's like I I understand wanting
to let stuff go and wanting to But you Oh, you I just realized
they're actually going to um
they're like going to blanket pardon everybody except Trump at
the end of this presidency, right? They're just going to blanket
pardon them all,
I
I think they'll just blanket pardon everybody. Like literally
everybody in our family, everybody who's a business associate,
we're just doing blanket pardons for everyone. >> So far
this year,
crazy, dude. It's crazy. >> That's not cool. What Don Lemon
just said is gross. >> I don't think you I think you can't
pardon yourself. I'm pretty sure you that's not a power vested
in you by the Constitution. You cannot pardon yourself. I'm pretty
sure.
Now, when he says that I had to do that pardon as a presidential
act, I guess we'll see what
>> It's gross. Period. It would be gross coming out of
a Republican's mouth. >> I had to I had to pardon somebody
who I didn't know as a presidential action.
>> It's gross coming out of a Democrat's mouth. And it
should be unilaterally
>> Yeah. It's actually transphobic. Ironically, Omar. Yep.
>> Yeah. So certainly what Don Lemon said is incredibly
distasteful and there's no way to defend it. But just on the
John Pierre bit, I do think frankly that diversity, equality,
and inclusion are important things. The United States has a very
racist history of excluding a lot of people and we should be
celebrating the fact that we are becoming a more inclusive society
where people of different backgrounds can rise uh to positions
that previously were simply inaccessible. Now, I agree with Jenk
that this becomes a problem when you start using it as a shield
to avoid the substance of conversations. and the recent interview
she had on MSNBC in which she's asked about whether she has any
regrets about the way she defended Biden's policies and war crimes
and what she responded with is her identity. That to me is a
misuse and an abuse of DEI. It's a way to trivialize that and
and essentially reduce identity politics is something distasteful
that becomes a source of criticism when absent these kinds of
abuses. I do think that there is room for identity politics in
a country that has excluded way too many people because of their
identity. And the fact that we're progressing beyond that is
frankly something to celebrate and to to look forward to. Okay.
I I prefer a I just prefer a general country where there's opportunity
for all from the grassroots up and then meritocracy overrides
mediocrity by ticking boxes. I think it's just so self harming
actually to the communities who people think they're trying to
help. I mean the classic example to me I just written a book
called Woke is dead. It's an aspiration, not a statement of fact.
Uh but I think the ideology is dying fast. The people reacting
to stuff on the woke side I think is just people have had enough
of it. But my classic was when Disney remade Snow White and the
Seven Dwarves and they decided that dwarf actors could not play
the dwarf roles. They therefore, as the dwarf actors told me,
deprived dwarf actors of the most prized roles in their business.
And they did it apparently to protect the interests of the dwarf
actors. If that isn't the most absurd example of of reverse identity,
>> uh, couldn't somebody who really believes in DI just
say this is bad >> politics self harming the very people
it's is purporting to protect? I don't know what is. Um, I was
going to mention one other thing. We run out of time, but I'm
going to give my view about this, which is Riley Gaines and Alexander
Okasio Cortez swapping insults. Gains saying the US was being
destroyed from within by AOC Mandani and Bernie Sanders. And
rather than respond to that, AOC responded by saying, "Maybe
if you channeled all this anger into swimming faster, you wouldn't
have come in fifth, which refers to the race which started Riley
Gain's campaign on behalf of women athletes in sport. Uh because
of course she was beaten by Leah Thomas, a 6'3 in biological
male uh who has been at the center of this absurd debate about
whether biological males who identify as trans women. No problem
with that. But what you can't do is compete against biological
women because there's a reason we separate the in the Olympics.
Women wouldn't win anything if we didn't. So, I just want to
say to Alexander Okes Cortez, who's never come on this show and
is always welcome. Would love to have her on. But when you attack
a woman who came fifth purely because you AOC support a policy
of allowing biological males to compete against women in sport,
you that's not the win you think it is. It's a big >> She
was fifth either way. She tied. She tied with a trans athlete.
>> It doesn't matter. It doesn't matter. the the trans
athlete should have been nowhere near that pool. >> Leah
Thomas won one race by Leah Thomas won run one race by 50 seconds.
50 seconds. It's ridiculous. Anyway, that's more of a monologue
than an
guys.
Riley Gains couldn't have helped coming in fifth.
She couldn't help it. Okay. Because there was one trans person
in the race. Can we just get her the fourth? Yeah, exactly. It's
like literally AOC just said if you were better at swimming you
wouldn't come in fifth. It's like fifth is not good. Are there
even what are there six lanes? Eight lanes
for the panel to all pin. Uh I >> whatever. [__]
it. Okay. All right. That was that was the Piers panel.
Some good stuff.
Kind of interrupted it with some other but I thought it was all
good mostly. For the most part it was all good. All right. I
have to lock in for this next segment. So, I'm going to have
to go get some caffeine. I'm going to try more caffeine cuz I
don't want to I don't want to end stream this early. Okay, consider
this a shill as well. I don't want to end stream in Oh sh We
must be really close. 11 minutes, guys. We're eight subs away
from another
two hours on the stream. Okay, two sub eight subs. Two hours.
Get your donations in now. I'm going to walk away for two seconds.
I'm going to start our Tactical Templar video. We're going to
watch his Pokemon video. All right.
Can watch him soy the out of about Pokemon man. Will this wake
you up?
Why would you send me this? Canadian caller. How attracted are
you to this
Okay. How attracted are you to this person? This is how we'll
gauge whether or not she's clockable.
1 to 10. Go. You
>> absolutely clockable.
>> Yeah, I realize you're gay. Yeah, that's what that's
why I'm asking. Thank you.
Okay. All right. Uh okay. Thank Marmma. Thank you for the gifted
sub. Consider this a shill. It's a shill right now. Okay, we've
got Tactical Templar, the Proopa videos, and then we've got the
Spooky Sunday stuff. So, I'm I'm going to try to get through
all of it. I'll open up Tactical Templar first.
We're going to watch this Pokemon video. Oh, okay. We're going
to watch this guy and then after this, we will Where will we
go after this? We will go to
the Proa stuff. Actually, I've got one clip after this for Tactical
Templar as well. But yeah, I'm assuming we'll hit some amount
of subs. Okay, I believe in you guys. 11 minutes, possibly 10
minutes now.
Seven more subs. Okay, I believe in you. Let's go,
>> brothers. You do not >> I picked I picked the
wrong thing. We're actually going to go with
Whoa. What is that? What is that? That's venomous villain with
five. We two subs away. We could totally do it. Okay, we're ready
for the Tactical Templar video. Jesus Christ.
Okay, I'm back.
Labbotomy stream pretty soon. Pretty soon. We'll see how it goes.
All right, Tactical Templar.
We need to watch that intro again. Wasn't that intro cool? Wasn't
that intro cool? This Tactical Templar with the Pokemon news.
Okay, when she posted apparently that some dude who was hitting
her up in DMs had gotten married. >> Seemed like unnecessary
information.
>> Oh, venomous villain. Thank you for the two. Let's go.
Carrying the carrying the stream. [laughter] I was I was broke.
We're no longer
>> Alibaba 7-Eleven. Thank you for the gifted zone.
>> Venomous villain carrying this hour of the stream. This
two hours of the stream. Thank you very much. And as well as
Alibaba. Okay. Thank you guys very much. [__] Are
you doing showbo content now too? This is not showbo content.
Okay. Despite the rumors, this is not showbo content. Let's continue.
brothers, you do not despise these female streamers enough. You
just don't. You may think that you do, but you don't. Pokemon
is in this clip right here that we're about to watch, and you're
not going to believe this, but there was a guy that was interested
in Pokemon that was DMing her for months.
She didn't even acknowledge this guy's existence. didn't respond
to any of the DMs. Didn't do anything with this guy. This guy
is going out there going, "I really hope that she'll give me
a chance this day. I really hope she'll give me a chance this
day." This guy living on a >> Do you think that Tactical
Templar is?
Do you think he's aware of like Shelbo and that lore? Do you
think he's aware of like the level of like crazy people who go
to Poky's DMs? Cuz it sounds like this must be a celebrity for
one thing because she wouldn't say anything if it wasn't somebody
consequential, right? Somebody she could check back in on and
see was getting married.
Is this dude getting winded just talking? Yes. Yes.
We've learned a lot about Tactical Templar recently. Apparently,
this guy loves Lolly VTubers.
I've just learned this. I've become aware of this recently.
All right. Maybe we'll watch some stuff in that vein at some
point. We'll see. Sent you a safe meme. All right. Well, I'm
I'm keep watching this for a second. I think this has to be like
a celebrity. So already he's like imagining himself. Like if
I message Pokemon, I wouldn't want her to out me. Don't worry,
bro. She She'll never see a DM from you. It will never matter.
Okay. I'm guessing actually all of her DMs go through like a
third party. And this was from somebody consequential enough
that they felt they had just still passed it on to her.
So anyway, it's it's like it won't happen to you. You don't have
to worry about it. Nobody has to hate her. in a prayer hoping
to get her attention. She's watching these things, not
The guy goes, "Okay, she's obviously not interested." The guy
moves on. He finds a girl who's willing to marry him
and he announces it on Instagram.
All of a sudden, Pokemon knows who this guy is and is reading
his Instagram
Again, the obvious implication here is that within like a very
short time frame, this guy went from hitting up Pokey consistently
to getting married to announcing his engagement.
Pokey likely thinks that that engagement had taken place over
a period of months and overlapped with him hitting up her. And
so he she felt like, "Oh, this is like some tea, but it like
I don't I'm not going to do it." She's just like, "Oh, I'm going
to make a nondescript video about it." Okay, maybe it's a little
weird, but it's not something to freak out about. And this guy
doesn't understand at all.
And now her master plan is, I wonder if I should DM the fiance
and tell her that he was DMing me.
No, I'm not kidding you.
She pretended this guy didn't exist.
This guy was really interested in her. He wanted to go on a date.
He wanted something from her. She didn't give him
So, the guy eventually moved on.
And that right there was the crime because Pokemon
loves >> Oh, he like actually straight up doesn't understand,
right?
Like, he straight up doesn't understand at all what the point
is here. He's like so disconnected from the female species that
he doesn't get it. He doesn't know what's happening. He doesn't
understand >> the attention. She loves everything to be
about herself. And this guy was giving her that. He was feeding
her ego,
you know, like the whole feeder syndrome. He was feeding her
bloated,
fat girl energy ego. >> This guy's definitely got
Pokemon inflation on his computer somewhere. Okay. 100%.
>> Just stuffing it.
And she loved it. She loved the feeling of control. Oh, I'm not
going to respond to this guy. This guy's not worth my time. I'm
Pokemon Man.
And then the guy moves on. He says, "You know what? This chick's
not worth it." Finds a girlfriend. Finds >> No, just to
be clear, if this was a stalker, Pokemon would not talk about
a stalker. This is a big streamer, big like influencer of some
kind who knew Pokey was single and was hitting her up and then
suspiciously got engaged very close to that. As in this guy,
she suspects he's like a player. The reason she would message
the fiance is because she's like, "Oh, nobody deserves to have
someone who would step out like that." Who got married? Maybe
got married. I I don't remember. No, just announced his
right? That's No, it's not Shelbo.
I'm just telling you what obviously has happened here based on
this and I think me listening to 5 seconds of the clip. Although
maybe the clip is maybe this is like a really bad title and the
clip says something totally different and then I'll be totally
wrong. >> A girl that's going to be his fiance
and Pokemon's first thought is I'm
mad
this guy isn't focused on me anymore. Now he's focused on his
own life. Now he's got a a girlfriend and a
>> Tell me why this guy has been DMing me for months, trying
to link up, responding to my outfit pics, etc., and he just announced
his engagement on
And it me off because it's in that gray area of like, I don't
think that this warrants messaging the girl and being like, "Hey
girl."
But also, it's
odd. Then again, maybe they're in an open rel. >> The only
thing here that's odd is that there was this guy that you didn't
give the time a day to. You didn't talk to according to you.
You didn't talk to him. You didn't respond to him. He >> Dude,
this is like such a straight incel script.
I don't even like literally this guy heard that Pokemon was talking
about someone in her DMs and he just filled in his entire life
story with every woman he's ever attempted DM to DM
>> instantly filled it in. >> Reban Ruben donated
$3. I would like to congratulate Shelbo on his engagement to
poke man. >> Thank you so
much donation
massive massive stuff. I'm actually secretly reconnecting my
headphones
to reconnect those headphones there for a second because the
[__] they started clicking again. I had to walk I
walked downstairs to get caffeine. So now I'm back. >> He
was DMing you. You weren't DMing him. So eventually he stops
DMing you and he finds a fiance. says, "I'm >> I normally
leave my headphones." Uh,
>> And you record yourself making a video,
and the thing that's really odd is that you thought this would
make you look good, but in fact, nothing could make you look
worse.
>> It's hard. >> It doesn't make her look any way.
It doesn't make her look any way. The only thing I would say
is somebody pointed out, there's probably a couple of like streamers
or highle influencers who just got engaged who are now like catching
questions from their fiance that they don't want to answer. You
know what I'm saying? And God bless those guys who are like actually
faithful and don't DM any other women because
they're actually they're actually probably the least trusted
now.
Oh, you like delete your DMs? Oh, you just like Okay. You think
I don't know she's referring to you? something that could really
break through and demonstrate your lack of a
You left this guy on unread for months, but he was being read.
You just didn't respond to him
because everything was about you and your [__] ego.
Well, I'm not the only one that noticed this.
So, wait,
she ignored him in the DMs. He moved on and now she's mad.
You explained it perfectly.
Auntie makes everything about her. Broke kept it pushing and
found somebody and she's getting shamed for it. Yes.
Yes. He's getting shamed
because he moved on and did the right thing and found a girl
that's willing to marry him. >> I'm I'm sorry. Is it not
like just It's just like so obvious that's not what would happen.
And I
It's so obvious. What? Man,
what do you think the odds are that Pokey even reads her own
DMs on most of her accounts? I'm guessing she's got one thing
like maybe an Insta or maybe her Twitter where she does read
her DMs where she can like filter them down a lot more. I don't
believe she reads her DMs in most places or like she has her
DM set to followers only. This could have actually been interesting.
Like if you try to DM Poke on some random platform, can you do
it? Hold on. Let me see if I can Let's see if I can go over to
Pokemon Man's actual Twitter and DM her. Boom.
I can. Why does she have open DMs on
That's bizarre that she'd have open I don't even follow her.
Well, hold on. Top Bronson. My theory is Okay. My theory
is that she has someone else who reads her DMs and passes along
things that are relevant and that even though this was somebody
trying to slide in her DMs, it was a big enough person that the
assistant would have thought it's relevant and I'm sending it
anyway. That's what I That's why I think it's like a big influencer
or something.
>> Instead of this obnoxious
midwit [__]
who again has that fat girl energy
when it comes to her ego.
She is a glutton when it comes to her ego.
She is one of the most vain content creators I've ever seen.
Everything about optics, everything about me me. What's the perception
of this? Like we are so we are so cooked as a species and people
like her are the
textbook definition of modern females. So she checks DMs for
people hitting on her,
then ignores them only to stalk them.
then post a video complaining about somebody moving on only to
think about ruining their happiness all out of this is like um
this is like the GPT thing like this guy's getting fooled. I
this is like actually blowing my brain up right now because I
kind of thought like okay I can still have some belief in humanity
if it's like just bots who are doing this who like don't actually
watch the clip. They're not capable of processing the clip. They
just read the comments and then they use that to interpret what
happened in the clip
and and that's now it's like a human who's
who is just reading the comments and not watching the clip, not
actually understanding the clip, right? So, it's like actually
destroying the cope I had that made me not think like the world's
doomed. It's kind of [__] up. >> Spite and
jealousy. >> This is very [__] up. I'll be
real. >> And y'all are on her side, man. >> I didn't
deserve this. Y'all are blinded by this hips. Yeah, I don't understand.
This is
>> Y'all are blinded by this by her hips. Y'all men y'all
are blinded by her hips.
What? This is like a very popular image right now. What? Can
someone tell me this looks like um Wizard of Oz or something?
Like it would be from Wizard of Oz. Sorry, not Wizard of Oz.
Oh my god. Alice in Wonderland. Alice in Wonderland. Alice in
Wonderland. But what is it?
I said it before I saw anybody say it in text. I instantly corrected
myself. I knew I knew it was Alice in Wonderland. Okay. Holy.
But what? Why is this popular right now? Why is this so popular
right at this specific point in time? >> Almost 40 and
is out here mad about some random dude. Yeah. Guess what, Pokemon?
This is the truth that none of your simps will tell. >> It's
only because Tech used it. I know Teone used it cuz I mocked
him for using it, but I thought I'd seen it like eight different
places before Tee used it. Thought I saw everybody using it.
>> Your eggs are drying up faster than if they had been
cracked [laughter] right on a skillet.
You are going >> Dude, Peter Molyneu must just hate his
life, right? Like, like he must just hate his life. Peter Molyneu
missed his window by like 10 years and he would have been like
a mil he would have been a millionaire easy. Stefan. God.
No, I'm talking about the guy who made the evolution game that
flopped.
That guy.
Lion's Head Studios, right? Steven Molyneu. I never watch Steven
Molyneu, so I I wouldn't know. I always screw it up. When When
I'm awake, yeah, when I when I'm awake, I screw them up. Oh,
>> to hit a point in time >> where your looks are
fading, your eggs have dried up, you have no kids, you have no
husband, you are going to be miserable and alone. And the thing
is, women like this are stupid enough to think that their money
is going to be able to compensate for the loneliness, the gaping
hole in their heart. No, it's
No amount of cats and boxes of wine are going to be able to compensate
for what you're about to feel hit you, which is the train called
father time.
And the fact that you're sitting here
about some >> There's no way.
This is like,
dude, we're going backwards in time.
We're going like backwards in time. People are doing like the
the owns from like the early internet. Don't these guys know
that they were already humiliated off the internet? Like the
people who thought this were already humiliated away? Like you've
already been humiliated. Why Why did you just come back and get
zero new talking
Yeah. Like you just you got zero new talking points. You've all
been humiliated. All those people have left in disgrace.
Random person that was >> Yeah. He's like the Japanese
guy in that island, right? the Japanese guy living in the middle
of the woods who like doesn't believe Imperial Japan would ever
surrender. So even though they tell him they surrendered, even
though they drop leaflets, he's like, "No, no, Japan never surrender."
Interested in you that you treated like and then he moved on
and now you're out here to try to get some kind of revenge.
These are the type of women
that ruin it for all women.
In fact, this is the type of woman. >> No, it's not even
it's not like about the eggs. It's like this is like an attitude
that just doesn't like doesn't work in so many ways, right? Like
yeah, Pooky's rich. She could do whatever she >> It will
just be okay. >> She's not going to have any problem having
kids at any point, right? >> Donated $5. The biggest indictment
of feminism is that this insult is somehow
>> Okay, I don't believe that. No, I don't believe that.
I don't I straight up don't believe that at all.
Who? Nobody believes that. Come on, be
be serious right now. Sure, sure. Sure, sure. I'm I'm saying
that like
Pokemon's probably set aside whatever she needs to for whatever
future she wants. She gets to do whatever she wants. She's retired
at like what? 32, 33, 34 Pokemon age.
She is 29. She's not even 30 yet. She's literally not even 30
yet, okay? And she's totally retired. She's all of her income.
There's literally nothing. She's like her life is totally set
for the rest of everything. She will never run out of money.
Her kids, if she has them, will likely never run out of money.
I just can't imagine
being in whatever position this guy's in. Okay, that he wants
to that he runs his YouTube channel and that's how he spends
most of his time and he's got enough time to be
about getting banned from Asmin Gold's Discord, right? Whatever
this guy is doing with his life, I know that Pokemon owns him
in every possible way.
that I would say
makes it so that we should repeal the 19th Amendment. Manipulative,
fake, self-absorbed, classless, gutter trash bimbo. And this
is unfortunately
the current state of content creation.
You literally left this guy on unread for months
and then you came back
and tried to ruin his life when he moved on.
>> Why did he get banned from Asminold's Discord? Uh, he
made a big thing about praying
is what I heard.
Someone sent me as like he's banned from Asmin Gold's Discord
cuz he wouldn't stop praying or something. I didn't I didn't
take a look yet. Um, apparently I don't want to I don't want
to talk about it. Apparently, this guy also has some other issues
going on. Okay. >> This is mad because she ignored him
and he moved on. >> Well, I can I can talk about it. This
guy apparently has like a KF thread or something and he covered
it on his stream. He's [__] insane.
Apparently, he got like a CF thread. He started covering it on
his stream.
Within like weeks,
within days, maybe. And
And it's like, bro, you don't Why Why would you do that?
>> Raise your thing? >> Cuz the >> Hold on.
I I'll grab the clip. Riyle sent me a clip of it or something.
He like pulled it up on stream. A couple different people told
me he pulled it up on stream.
One second. Let me go find this. Can we say a prayer for Kiwi
Let's Let's bow our head. Let's Let's say a prayer for Kiwi Farms.
Dear Lord, we come before you and we just pray for the lost and
broken souls over
>> I'm not lying when I said
he made it skinnier. He made his night skinnier. He started getting
made fun of for being fat and he made a skinnier night. There's
a skinnier night now.
I'm not even joking. I said this the other day. I'm like, wait,
there's no way he made the skinnier, right? And he made it skinnier.
He actually went and made it. There's no shot, bro.
>> Because the is this she >> Oh, wait. Hold on.
Let's finish the the prayer. I do want to finish the prayer.
Lord, you know that a lot of those people are in a miserable
place.
Many of them have given up, stopped trying to reach out, stop
trying to
feel anything approaching goodness and light.
Lord, I just pray in your own way that you touch each of their
lives, that you have somebody reach out and try to bring them
back to the church so that they may know your love and grace
and
Lord, I just pray that you give them
that you find them something to do
other than
the distractions
and the I just want to make it clear that we uh listen, we laugh
at this guy not because he's praying. We laugh at this guy because
he's praying as a shield, okay? And not a shield because he's
like a s or something. Not for women. He's a he's he's using
it as a shield to distract from the fact that he loves drawn
dep
drawn depictions of children. Okay. That's his favorite thing
in the whole world. Okay. The younger the better for this guy
in terms of his like lolly enjoyment. All right. And he uses
he uses his whole Christian LAR as a shield. It's so gross.
Ignored him and he moved on. Now she's mad. The wall and the
smell of rotten eggs are close. That's right. That's
>> It's such a mind. He can pray like that and talk about
Pokemon the way he does. It's also why I suspect he's not actually
married. >> The wall is undefeated.
She should tell the girl. Uno reversed the girl with a picture
of the ring and says, "I have the ring. You left him on
And also reply uh with the rabbit tapping the clock. That would
be really
Who is that fella, bro? Too damn bad.
Is she seriously mad that guy um has been sing over her finally
moved on? Yes, she is.
Yes, she is. Because Pokemon and other girls in that space, and
I'm sure this happens with Valkyrie.
>> hold on. Can you read? No. Oh, what you'll notice about
this guy is not unlike the borderline illiterate classmate in
fifth grade who has to use their finger to sound out each word.
That's what tact Tactical Templar does with like all of the things
he reads on stream. Watch the finger move along. I'm >> mad.
Is she seriously mad that guy um has been sing over finally moved
on? Yes, she is.
Yes, she is. >> She does it like all the time. Pokemon
and other girls in that space, and I'm sure this happens with
Valkyrie and Cinnamon,
Emaru, and Extra Emily and all these other people,
they get these very flattering posts
and DMs and messages, and they do they get off on it. They feel
very flattered and they feel very important,
but it's it's not that they want to respond or that they they
like the guy or that they're going to, you know, flirt with it
just like
>> Reban Rubin donated $3. Templar probably got the thinner
curse through chain >> Like the fact that there are people
that are DMing them and interested in them and that makes them
feel good
and they don't care about anyone else.
So Pokemon left the guy on >> Thank you so much for the
three Ruben Ruben. I love you. I got to get you sometimes. Okay.
Once in a while I have to I have to poke once in a while or else
or else you'll just start phoning it in. Okay. I have to let
you know that I've got like a bar and then
otherwise you just end up phoning it in. >> He moved on
eventually and that's it. Now she's mad. Now she's mad because
she
that well she isn't all that.
that guys can move on and that bothers her because it reminds
her of choo choo father time
coming around the track.
You're This is why I've got to neg him occasionally. Ozel. Okay.
If he has his full self-esteem, he might realize he could do
anything with his life and be anywhere. And so I have to neg
him occasionally so he never looks away. So he's always always
knows he's here. Okay. If I if I just tell him he's awesome all
the time, he'll think about moving on to bigger and better places.
We can't have that. You're pushing what? 35, 40.
She looks like she's 40 now. She She's getting up there in age.
Yeah. She She's looking old. >> Trying to
>> like I I'm sorry.
That's incredibly
I just don't know.
Woman who sells products and like an entire brand based on how
how she looks looks old, looks 40, looks beat
I'm so I'm sorry, man. I What a [__] What a what
a Don't DM girls like this.
Don't DM girls like this. They'll use it to try to destroy you
to make themselves feel better about themselves.
Don't do it. It's not worth it. It's not worth it. You guys can
do better.
You guys can do better than a midwit, a girl that thinks she's
a girl boss but is what? 80 IQ.
A girl that has sacrificed everything for her quoteunquote career
ends up miserable, ends up alone. She's gonna be
So,
don't feel bad for her. She's awful. She's miserable.
And uh it's only a matter of time.
You know, you can call it karma. You can call it divine retribution.
But things have a way of uh working
>> dude. Okay. I I'm sorry.
The divine retribution of making this woman retired at 30 with
every door possible open for her. She could do anything she wants
with her life. She never has to worry about money or work again.
She just gets to choose to do whatever. I Bro,
what was she in another life for this to be the retribution out?
>> We have a god of justice and love, but we also have
a god of wrath. >> What's up, Crow? How's it going? >> Anyway,
ladies and gentlemen, I want to thank you for watching. ing.
I want to thank you for supporting the channel and I'll see you
next time. >> Wow,
that's
Tactical Templar. The Son [__] explodes at his audience.
I'd think about it. I'd think about it, but Oh, I would think
about it.
Ah,
what's this? Porter Beller gave me a clip. Hold on. Porter Beller
had a clip. Let me find it.
I was told this was some goofy. Let me see. What was it? Oh,
it's a dot move. Oh, give me a second. Got to put this on stream.
I got to put this on streamable. How do we get it up there? What
is this? What is this? I By the way, I've not I've not spent
time like figuring out what this was about. This is from a video
that
seems weird,
but it's not real. AI generated child art could be the next big
problem. Okay.
Car. Okay. Why? Why is this taking what the streamable? Can you
go? SH is taking forever here. Give me a second. We're letting
this We're letting this load up.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Nobody's seen this clip,
right? I'm just I'm a little scared about this clip. Templar
armor avatar for future segments. We could do a Templar bit.
I don't want to I don't want to get into bullying this guy too
much. As much as I hate this guy and he is like a huge local,
I once everyone else like when when we were doing it and no one
else was doing it, I feel fine. And then once everyone else is
in, I'm like, "Okay, I want to move on."
Same thing happened with Tom Foolery, right? It's like, "Okay,
now everybody else is bullying this guy. I just want to move
on." I I don't like it when it's like eight different content
creators doing all of it at the same time.
>> But this is going to open up a conversation in the coming
years. People
are going to be asking this because if you have an AI program
that can generate child, but no children were actually hurt in
the creation of this, what is going to be the public's conversation?
there are many different topics
that I would have said to you there is no possible way that that
topic is going to go the way that it is. >> Where are my
prison bar sound effects?
Should have them somewhere here. There it is. I >> mean,
if you would asked me
15 years ago
like about wokeness and that whole thing, I would have said there's
no way.
There's no way that some of the more
>> of wokeism
were going to make its way into public
No. Uh-uh. Not going to happen. But they did.
And by the way,
I just scrolled up here to look at this. >> Oh, well that's
the big thing, Shogunate. I think people have been looking into
this guy, finding like some of his old videos and he used to
run a lot of defense for like VTubers and stuff. He used to be
like a big time
So, I don't know. I don't know what happened. Yeah, I don't know
what happened. I don't know how he decided to go into the conservative
grift. Okay. >> This picture and a detail that I didn't
>> But that's why he has Nuaku and uh he's got like Nuxtaku
and Tecton as his paragonss of virtue, right? because they're
both former Gooners.
[laughter] That former is said with a lot of, you know, we're
knocking on wood there. Okay. Former Gooners
who are now for some reason conservative in some >> We
noticed
was that these three girls um in this the Wendy's have condoms
in their mouth.
>> I know the picture he's talking about, too. It's weird.
But uh there's like a picture that he's talking about that I'm
not going to pull up cuz it's just goon bait. It's just goon
fuel. No thanks. No